ok tu te mets en place terrier je suis
en place
la nouvelle émission tu fais une entrée
je fais pas ce soir tu l'as fait pas non
faut que je fasse une entrée
ok ok je fais une entrée ok ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec nous ce soir Eddy Mitchell
et Christine Scott Thomas Christine de
Vienne j'encourt pierre
Sardou
Marilyn Manson
nightcore
Simon libératif et mon ami dans ma vie
[Musique]
voici Eddy Mitchell
enfin
alors Eddy vous êtes pas venu pour rien
tiens un livre un album illustré de 100
photos un texte de Sam bernette qui
raconte votre vie du rockeur au crooner
voilà alors c'est un livre très
intéressant parce que moi ce que j'aime
en fait dans les bio des stars c'est
l'enfance voilà alors naissance en 42 du
côté de la Place des Fêtes dans le 19e
arrondissement vos parents s'appellent
Lucienne et Robert c'est nerveux
non mais ça fait un peu film de Lelouch
tu sais
Marcel et oui je sais c'est un peu ça la
sœur s'appelle Gisèle et le frère
s'appelle Pierre vous vous êtes le petit
dernier le petit gâté
le soir pour pour dîner vous dites on
met un morceau de de pain dans un bol de
vin rouge quoi c'est quand même pas ah
ça c'est l'été l'hiver c'est quoi une
bonne grosse soupe non oui et puis la
fin du mois se termine le 15 très
souvent
alors dans la famille dédie mise à part
votre père qui travaille à la RATP la
nuit tout le monde travaille au Crédit
Lyonnais donc vous vous retrouvez
coursier à l'agence Richelieu-Drouot
bientôt vous êtes virés parce qu'en tant
que coursier évidemment vous barrez sur
la petite mobylette et vous allez tout
faire sauf du travail et et finalement
vous êtes viré mais cette expérience
vous permet de découvrir ce qu'on
appelle le triangle d'or c'est-à-dire
entre les grands boulevards le square de
la Trinité la rue Richelieu et là vous
rencontrez deux autres glandeurs
passionnés de rock qui sont Johnny
Hallyday et Jacques Dutronc et ce que je
trouve assez extraordinaire quand même
c'est cette rencontre quoi les trois
plus grands jouaient ensemble à
l'adolescence c'est très bizarre quand
même
c'est le hasard extraordinaire
surtout de merveilleux c'est qu'on soit
resté non seulement en très bon terme
mais qu'on soit vraiment des amis Dick
Rivers c'est marrant la vie
si je mais bien c'est ça et lui il était
niçois et alors bientôt vous découvrez
le Golf Drouot qui deviendra le berceau
du rock français nous quand on l'a connu
c'était un endroit pour vieille dame qui
venait prendre le thé
au-dessus du café d'Angleterre c'était
vraiment un mini colf un golf miniature
donc 400 trous j'en sais rien et voilà
c'est rien ouais alors ce qui est drôle
c'est votre première rencontre c'est je
savais pas avec Jean-Philippe Smet donc
futur Johnny Hallyday il vous pique des
disques mais c'est vrai bon ben
à côté pas très loin de 8h et des
martyrs c'est une une surprise partie
comme l'on dit et donc bon j'avais amené
des listes comme tous les gamins comme
tout comme nous étions et en partant
quand ça se termine il faut les
embarquer et les miens je les trouvais
pas il y avait mon camarade Johnny qui
lui les avait confié au concierge
en disant je repasserai les prendre plus
tard et là vous le collez au mur quand
même vous récupérez
45 tours de Vincent ça s'oublie pas donc
entre Johnny et vous ça a commencé par
un baston quoi oh baston
de gamins et puis pourquoi tu aimes ça
bah parce que moi j'aime ça et puis
voilà et d'un seul coup on a parlé de
choses beaucoup plus importante qui
était
un vrai dandy
chapeau enfoncé jusque aux oreilles
imperméable cintré à la taille oui c'est
vrai qu'il avait un côté on l'appelait
Gaston d'accord car il se tenait exprès
pour le gag se tenait toujours goûté
avec un imperméable et à l'époque il
avait des foyers triples triple des
Verts triple foyers comme ça et quand il
l'arrière on appelait ça l'opération
gitane voilà c'était avant sa
métamorphose parce qu'après les animaux
après c'est devenu le playboy que l'on
connaît qu'il est toujours d'ailleurs
c'est l'époque où vous récoltez le
surnom de shemale
c'était un peu dur quand même c'était
même pas humiliation c'était
consternation
non non c'est tout ça était pas
important parce que on pensait qu'on
allait faire qu'on avait fait un disque
c'était amusant et puis qu'on allait
et c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai non
nous avons aujourd'hui
en tous les cas le succès est immédiat
vous avez du succès tout de suite avec
tu parles trop bebopolula Daniela et
vous vendez en deux ans deux millions de
disques comme ça à l'époque c'était
c'est énorme
vous prenez ça comme ça mais c'est quand
même extraordinaire oui mais à l'époque
on trouve ça normal
plus le truc drôle c'est que c'est vrai
ah bon bah c'est bien c'est formidable
et puis on n'avait pas enfin on se
rendait pas bien compte
un problème c'est que vous partez à
l'armée et dites donc
soyez tranquille si on fait votre vie à
4h du matin un moment à un moment il
faut qu'on leur rendement
voilà alors après vous faites quelques
succès il y a toujours un coin qui me
rappelle s'il n'en reste qu'un Alice
enfin des débuts de votre carrière solo
donc il y a quand même une longue
traversée du désert j'ai revu ça en
lisant ce bouquin je me souvenais pas ça
va mal il y a une période comme ça qui
dure 4-5 ans où vous êtes quand même euh
4 ans quand même hein
ils envisagent même de reformer les
chaussettes non enfin vous voulez pas un
homme c'était
pour dire à quel point ça allait mal
quand même oui oui non mais c'est vrai
que je vendais très très peu de disques
et
que ce qu'il faisait peur c'est que les
anciens disques qui étaient
reproposé en conflit en sociologue
oui le best of des chaussettes noires
c'est le vendait mieux que vos disques
c'est terrible ça ça arrive à Dave tous
les ans vous me direz il était pas dans
les chaussettes noires
à ce moment-là vous faites une émission
de fait une émission de radio qui
s'appelle en attendant que ça se passe
donc c'est bien la preuve que vous aviez
le sentiment quand même que c'était un
mauvais moment qui ne marche pas non
plus hein
enfin c'est drôle c'est pas drôle c'est
je rigole qui s'appelle au fond du
trouble qui marche pas du tout alors du
coup vous viviez de quoi à l'époque j'ai
tourné où j'avais pas envie d'aller
d'ailleurs je tenais dans les pays de
l'Est
Roumanie machin tout ça avec le chou
farci tout ce qu'on aime bien et
et je gagnais très bien ma vie mais
c'était pas très drôle non et là c'est
le drame maintenant justement Laurent
c'est le grand retour
comme un nouveau-né
monstre à pantalon
c'était la dernière séance
de la dernière séance elle semblait bien
dans sa peau ses yeux couleur ment
[Musique]
je suis papa
je suis beau comme ça
avec cette élite en club
c'est version
sont extraits du CD le flexitor donc ça
c'est des trucs que vous avez chanté il
y a il y a un an quoi exactement
la nouvelle chanson ça non non non
c'est des interprétations d'aujourd'hui
de chansons
c'est incroyable 40 ans après avoir
commencé vous êtes toujours là vous avez
la pêche les gens vous applaudissent
pas unique dans ce cas je bon c'est
c'est merci merci tous les jours
tu vas voir on a pas fini d'en bouffer
[Musique]
ce qu'on a laissé
retenu
ça demande pas
Eddy Mitchell
je chante pour ceux qui ont le blues
alors Eddy vous êtes
vous êtes un rocker maintenant je sais
pas si vous êtes une rockstar on va
faire un test le rock-star test
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes né dans la rue
j'ai pas de souvenirs
la boîte à chaussures avec les billets
dedans
donc j'ai mis un pain et puis est-ce que
vous avez déjà couché avec votre cousine
je joue pas de piano non plus est-ce que
vous êtes déjà mort dans un accident
d'avion non s'il rappelle toi la réponse
est non c'est pas sympa je le prends
dans 2 jours est-ce que vous avez déjà
saccagé une chambre d'hôtel
une fois est-ce que vous avez déjà fait
une overdose au Palace
non non j'ai déjà chanter du Charles
Trenet
quoi
est-ce que vous avez déjà chanté avec
Maurice Chevalier
c'est mauvais ça pourrait être Rockstar
ah bon
le twist du canotier est-ce que vous
avez déjà été inquiété pour des
problèmes de drogue dans un aéroport
américain
ça c'est perdu ça c'est pas gentil
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose en
vous de Tennessee regarde bien
non mais enfin ça c'est pareil quand on
l'a quand on connaît les tendances
sexuelles de Tennessee Williams vaut
mieux pas d'accord bonne réponse vous
avez déjà été agressé par un fan
honnêtement pas non quoi ah non non
j'ai déjà allé sur le plateau de la Star
Academy pour faire de la promo oui deux
fois
alors moi je vérifie
là on y va bien on y va
est-ce que vous avez été de boire ou de
fumer non plus ah ça c'est bien bon pour
être Rockstar c'est bien ah bon les
excès il faut faire beaucoup d'excès ah
bon j'ai beaucoup de boulot
vous vous jetez dans votre public à la
fin d'un concert
bonsoir
vous êtes vous êtes rare à la télévision
vous voir Armand sur les plateaux de
télévision on est dans d'autant plus
content et flatté que vous soyez là
Christine voilà merci alors je sais que
vous aimez pas les gens qui sont
impressionnés par vous vous dites ça me
met mal à l'aise alors je vais essayer
de pas être trop impressionné par vous
donc moi les gens me la laissent ça
m'impressionne
alors en fait je crois que vous n'êtes
pas du tout consciente de l'effet que
vous produisez vous dites les gens
fantasmes à cause de mes rôles ils
imaginent que j'ai une espèce de pouvoir
de séduction c'est archi faux
je peux pas élaborer mais oui oui
très séduisant
c'est très sympathique merci en fait
Christine se trouve pas belle mais si
elle le dit elle a peur de passer pour
quelqu'un qui aurait de la fausse
modestie donc c'est très compliqué
ça vous rend encore plus attachante et
plus belle
alors vous êtes né en Angleterre d'une
famille très chicout bah comme il faut
quand même une famille comme il faut une
famille normale
alors votre vie ça commence comme un
roman votre père était pilote de chasse
il est mort quand vous aviez 5 ans votre
mère se remarie avec un autre pilote de
chasse qui meurt 6 ans après c'est
incroyable non
et très difficile pour elle et pour nous
les enfants c'était très difficile enfin
ça c'est des choses qu'on qui nous
fabriquent des expériences comme ça
c'est des choses qui qui nous donne nos
caractères donc faut pas pleurer c'est
réussi vous avez commencé la comédie
très tôt
à l'âge de 4 ans vous jouiez un berger
un vieux berger en effet avec une canne
c'est pas un peu tard quatre ans pour
jouer un vieillard
mais là très vite vous êtes aperçu que
c'était là que vous étiez bien quoi
c'était quand vous étiez en
représentation j'aimais beaucoup me
déguiser et faire semblant d'être
quelqu'un d'autre et je continue c'est
ce soir vous faites l'actrice qui a fait
un film avec Régis varnie vous le faites
très bien d'ailleurs merci alors votre
famille vous décourage de faire de la
comédie parce que par sens des
convenances ça se faisait pas et vous
décidez de devenir professeur d'art
dramatique ce qui était une sans doute
une mauvaise idée
oui enfin je me suis inscrit dans un
dans une classe où on apprenait à être
professeur et je me suis vite aperçu que
c'était vraiment pas la bonne voie et
que pour faire ce que je voulais faire
il fallait que je quitte l'Angleterre et
que je recommence à nouveau quelque part
ailleurs et voilà et c'est là que la
France a hérité de Christine Scott
Thomas vous aviez 19 ans vous êtes venu
ici comme jeune fille au pair dans une
famille et c'est cette famille qui vous
encouragé à faire le métier d'actrice
que je voulais faire
et c'était à cause d'ailleurs je me
souviens très bien j'avais tellement
peur d'aller au
concours de la rue Blanche que qu'elle
m'a mis elle-même dans elle a appelé un
taxi elle m'a mis
et donc vous êtes jamais reparti de
France mais ma maison chez moi
en médecine
aujourd'hui un grand médecin quelle
spécialité
c'est il est obstétricien
c'est pas un mot facile non plus hein
vous êtes trois grands enfants et alors
à cause d'eux à cause de ses enfants
donc vous n'avez pas fait de carrière
Hollywood c'est parce que j'ai choisi de
privilégier la vie française la vie que
je pouvais trouver ici avec ma famille
mes enfants plutôt que cavaler là-bas et
et avoir à faire des choses
qui m'attiraient plus tellement en fait
je suis allée je suis j'ai fait un tour
et puis je suis revenu
vous regrettez pas jamais si parfois
quand les enfants pleurent
si parfois on se dit Oh j'aurais dû
rester et puis on a plus de liberté ici
bizarrement
américain c'est très très difficile et
là vous voyez les rôles que je viens de
jouer là uniquement en France avec
Arsène Lupin et puis manthuman et petit
coupure
c'est fantastique c'est fabuleux c'est
méchante en ce moment oui j'ai eu une
période méchante c'est fini là j'ai
plutôt dans les comédies
alors en préparant cette interview je me
suis rendu compte que c'est pas la
première fois que vous jouiez avec avec
des pygmées
en 86 vous avez fait under the cherry
Moon avec Prince
vous l'avez pas mis dans votre
filmographie
je suis très fière de ce film c'était
mon premier film je jouais au théâtre
dans un champ en Bourgogne une pièce de
Marguerite Duras c'est tout d'un coup on
m'appelle pour me demander d'aller faire
des essais avec Prince qui était à
l'époque
limousine en allant à Nice j'avais
jamais essayé dans un hôtel de ma vie
jusque là et là c'était les hôtels 4
étoiles c'était mignon quoi
alors vous êtes sans doute l'anglaise
qui connaît le mieux les Français
je crois qu'on est plusieurs à connaître
alors on va faire un french quiz
[Musique]
alors Christine est-ce que le français
fait tout le temps la gueule oui
voilà
et encore rappelons qu'elle ne prend pas
le métro
est-ce que le Français a vraiment une
hygiène douteuse
est-ce que le français se croit vraiment
supérieur aux autres non
vous pensez que les Français
je me sens quand même adoptée et je me
suis adaptée
vous parlez beaucoup mieux le français
que tiennent bien
est-ce que le français vraiment nul en
langue étrangère
pas aussi mieux que les Anglais
est-ce que le français est vraiment prêt
à dénoncer son voisin si on le lui
demande oui ah est-ce que le français
arnaque vraiment les touristes quand ils
viennent en France ah ça je sais pas
parce que j'ai jamais été tout récent en
France
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que le français est draguer
j'ai du mal à repérer les dragons en
fait même pendant la l'acte
est-ce que le français passe vraiment
son temps à parler de sexe
non est-ce que le français Ambroise bien
est-ce que le français fait bien l'amour
est-ce que le français est sympathique
n'en demande pas trop tirer
[Applaudissements]
magnifique Christine de vierge en cours
c'est du quoi ça du lapin
et comment ça va ça va pas mal Christine
de la République
on vous a connu chanteuse et maintenant
vous êtes écrivain non mais j'ai écrit
quatre livres c'est le cinquième
pour me défendre me battre là on souffle
on parle d'autre chose et on parle de on
parle de cul de la vraie vie Christine
vous êtes une vraie touche à tout non
oui oui
allez allez bien alors ensuite Christine
on vous a connu chanteuse et là on a
découvert avec super moment de la sortie
du disque que toute votre enfance
veuillez travailler le piano avec un
grand musicien espagnol qui avait fui le
franquisme qui s'était réfugié à Sarlat
et que normalement vous auriez dû être
Christine de vigencourt chef d'orchestre
j'ai pas qui a mené le retour à mon avis
c'est dur de commencer à 55 ans pour une
jeune chanteuse
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi sérieusement Christine vous
pensez quoi de ces nouveaux chanteurs
qui ne savent pas chanter qui vendent
des millions d'albums alors que vous en
vendez beaucoup moins vous savez pas
chanter non plus
je crois que d'abord j'ai eu envie de
décrire c'est une façon de m'exprimer
c'est ce qui m'a motivé en même temps la
musique j'ai toujours baigné et bon si
ça marche ça marche moi je me fais
plaisir c'est le principal vous auriez
dû chanter pour ceux qui sont loin de
chez eux et qui ont dans les yeux
quelque chose qui fait mal
c'était de pas avoir écrit vos chansons
vous-même
bien j'ai un secret je l'écoute à la
bonne vitesse
alors donc un [__] de la République
deux chanteuses 3 écrivains
un livre après un disque voulait
vraiment retourner en prison Christine
non parce que là je risque rien parce
que là ça parle pas d'affaires d'État
par rapport à votre passé vous auriez
pas mieux fait de sortir une ligne de
chaussures non
ça m'intéresse pas la chaussure
alors le livre s'appelle comme le disque
toi masculin mon féminin c'était aux
éditions du Rocher et c'est un roman
érotique alors vous dites j'ai écrit ce
livre pour ne pas mourir au lendemain du
procès on appelle après la relaxe Dumas
en voyant que je prenais encore les
coups c'est vrai que j'ai passé quelques
mois très dur
je n'avais plus tellement d'avenir et
d'enlever ce membre tu méfier semble
prendre naissance et voilà j'ai la Gaule
j'ai noté aussi quelques passages
c'est l'histoire d'une femme la dérive
qui vit encore dans le souvenir du grand
amour de sa vie
le grand amour de sa vie c'est un homme
plus âgé qu'il a marqué à jamais mais
qu'il l'a jamais épousé et qui est mort
Roland Dumas est mort
non je sais pas donc je peux pas cacher
qu'effectivement l'héroïne je me suis
complètement cliquée en elle parce que
j'avais aussi à travers à travers elle
j'avais besoin de lire des choses donc
effectivement et aussi peut-être j'ai
voulu montrer une femme une femme qui
s'est battue une femme qui a pris des
sacré coups dans la gueule et cette
femme se retrouve dans bah par terre
quoi
avec cet homme elle n'a plus rien elle
est complètement la vérité et elle
retombe amoureuse alors d'un mec qui au
départ est très macho et on découvre
rapidement que c'est une folle tordue
il adore espaces
on a tous en nous du masculin du
je suis très féminine je crois que j'ai
beaucoup de masculin en moi et je me
suis dit en écrivant ce livre je crois
que j'avais besoin de vivre une histoire
d'amour que je vis pas c'est vrai je
suis un peu seul depuis 7 ans et je me
suis immergée là dedans et je me suis
dit voyons quel est le genre d'homme qui
pourrait me faire me faire peut-être
traquer
un homme en fait qu'il soit l'inverse de
moi c'est-à-dire à la fois masculin et
féminin
en plus tu as déjà pris ton pied dans le
9 3 c'est quoi le 9 3 ah oui la banlieue
9 3 non je suis pas allé mais aussi
je connais personne là tu vas connaître
du monde très bien et ben on va y aller
ça te donnera un autre livre page 24
donc c'est un soir glacé de pleine lune
donc vous êtes vous êtes avec le vieux
c'est avant
elle se déshabille derrière un fourré il
fait très froid il fait froid bien sûr
je venais à lui des vêtus voilà et alors
je ne craignais plus ce froid de mort
qui m'envahissait comme une douleur
j'avançais encore j'imaginais le
spectacle qui s'offrait à lui et je
jubilé à 1 m de lui je m'arrêter il
s'approcha
ôta ça va ce qu'il posait à même le sol
sur l'herbe givrée ces imams et l'invita
et m'invita à m'allonger j'obéis encore
me recouvrer sans aucun préliminaire il
écarte à mes jambes en tout cas c'est
bien conjugué parce que tu vois
rien
et bien conjugué en tout cas
ceinture brutale comme un viol je sentis
ça que raide me pénétrer écarter les
chers comme une déchirure son désir
était violent impatient ses coups de
boutoir
c'est fou de boutoir redoubler au fond
de mon ventre voilà
voilà ça c'est la mort du vieux quoi
pratiquement
et donc effectivement après cette
aventure avec ce cet homme disant d'un
âge mur
l'héroïne est complètement déboussolée
elle prête à quitter Paris et là elle
rencontre le fameux Francesco qui est un
riche businessman alors il y a un truc
que je supporte pas c'est qu'il est fier
de frauder le fisc
c'est une image ah non c'est pas une
image moi je trouve que c'est pas bien
il est comme beaucoup c'est à dire 20%
de français aujourd'hui qui se demandent
comment ils vont faire et qui se
délocalise c'est vrai que c'est dommage
de la France vous dites la réussite
qu'il faut planquer sous peine de délit
d'abus biens sociaux c'est pas vrai
quand sur l'argent propre sur lequel on
a payé ses impôts on peut s'acheter tout
ce qu'on veut en France ce qui est
interdit c'est acheter des trucs
au moins ça va à quelqu'un ça aide les
gens ça fait des crèches
c'est vrai qu'ils sont très élevés c'est
vrai qu'il y a des gens qui s'en vont ça
quelque chose moi je paye des impôts et
je bénéficie pas de certaines choses
comme un citoyen normal quoi j'appelle
la police c'est pas la même histoire
quoi ils viennent quand ils appellent
pas les problèmes
quand je lis la réussite qu'il faut
planquer sous peine de délits d'abus de
biens sociaux c'est pas vrai quand on
peut s'acheter ce qu'on veut avec
l'argent
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui monte une
entreprise qui a la force du poignet
pendant des années la montrer sa propre
entreprise a créé de l'emploi et qui moi
ça arrive j'entends ça autour de moi
tous les jours et qui achète je sais pas
j'exagère mais un billet d'avion pour
les vacances c'est de la Budokai
parce que je vais vous dire ça c'est de
la butte bien sociale effectivement
c'est acheter des billets d'avion pour
aller en vacances sur les frais de la
société
c'est un abus de bien social et c'est
interdit et c'est normal voilà
mais enfin quand même à un moment les
gens ne connaissent pas tout ça ils
demandent même pour des petites
distances
même pour les petits si c'est pas
professionnel on paye avec son pote
moi je suis là bon alors elle baise avec
Francesco donc alors vous dites un amant
la reprise un amant
chez vous qui avez écrit le bouquin
c'est pas moi
alors ils vont en vacances ensemble et
là il commence à porter des
sous-vêtements féminins ouais c'est
effectivement le mec est assez chaud là
quelle page quelle page 82 se fait plus
rageuse et secoue la palmeraie les
parfums de mer du musée de jasmin sont
enivrantes effluves le tissu s'envole
parce que le mec a mis la nuisette
les parfums de mer du Muse et de jasmin
sont délivrants et fluves le tissu
s'envole découvrant sa nudité jusqu'à la
taille du mec
en retombant tout en plaquant la soie
sur son ventre le pan de la chemise
s'accroche sur son sexe tendu qu'il
laisse ainsi offert comme une insulte
une provocation
brutale nous dit que signe de vieilles
en cours devant lui je m'agenouille
doucement
à travers le vêtement de peau d'ange je
les fleurs du bout des doigts qu'est-ce
que ça virilité dessinée sous le velouté
du tissu je peux plus m'excite davantage
alors ça va jusqu'au dîner à la fin il y
a un dîner où il arrive maquiller le mec
il pousse à l’extrême
maquiller je maquiller avec un
porte-jarretelles parce que je trouve ça
aussi
Jérôme
c'est ma mère
ils font un dîner fin le mec se maquille
il met un porte-jarretelle il se couche
par terre c'est des idées pour vous avec
avec votre canadien et alors vous dites
ni femelle ni homme les cuisses serrées
le sexe démesuré offert
la mensuration
et alors c'est le moment où elle
l'attache
elle mouille son doigt pour titiller ses
seins le bout de ses seins du mec je
m'en parle sur ce pieu démesuré qui me
déchire le ventre c'est toujours le
ventre c'est jamais la chatte c'est
bizarre pour un livre de cul c'est très
bizarre
hyper chaud j'avais le cul laminé
calciné et incrusté d'une épaisse croûte
noire
j'avais le effectivement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est quoi Christine sérieusement
j'y crois plus
c'est un rêve ça de j'ai besoin d'amour
et je me suis créé une histoire comme ça
et en l'écrivant j'ai vécu quelque chose
et j'ai oublié le reste les affaires
d'état la couleur des cheveux de l'homme
idéal pour vous
la coupe de cheveux
musclé musclé il y a tous les
échantillons
je m'en fous quel bord politique voulait
qu'il soit qui soit donc un bord rien du
tout religion je m'en fous la première
chose que l'homme idéal doit vous dire
en se levant
au revoir
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
[Musique]
et voilà ce que Évelyne dit Pierre
ça va pas mal c'est lamentable comme
d'habitude vous êtes d'accord
comment ça va c'est lamentable
on est bien barré je sens bien ça sent
bien petit Intermarché Laurent Baffie
qui est quand même un dramaturge lui
aussi je crois qu'on peut le dire c'est
vrai heureusement vous avez fait un
petit bout dans le film de Laurent parce
que sinon je sais pas ce qu'on
retiendrait de votre
et d'ailleurs ça a booster un peu ta
carrière ça m'a fait ça m'a fait un bien
faire travailler un peu comme Nagui tu
sais j'étais un peu un peu dans le
au top il est au top là au top au top
alors j'ai vu Evelyne chez Michel
Drucker il y a quelques temps oh là là
il vous a demandé il vous a demandé
quelque chose de très grave il vous a
dit est-ce que c'est pas difficile de
jouer avec l'homme dont on partage la
vie c'est vrai qu'il fallait penser à
cette question
regarde
ce rameau mais vraiment je l'adore quand
tu dis ça
truc tu voudrais pas faire une interview
trop emmerdante donc je vais vous
épargner non mais c'est une bonne
question en plus c'est vrai mais
répondez
que vous l'avez vu la télé
le dimanche après-midi c'est ravissant
franchement il y a tous vos copains qui
sont venus dire vous étiez formidables
et oui mais j'aimerais bien la faire
cette émission de modèle des gens qui
ont des amis oui c'est ça le problème
tu crois que moi ça marcherait pas
attends attends
10 minutes ouais 10 minutes pierre non
sérieusement j'ai lu dans Marie Claire
du mois de novembre
j'aime beaucoup Marie-Claire c'est un
très bon choix j'ai lu Comment comment
quoi Thierry juste après une première
rencontre un soir dans une chambre qui
servait de loge Évelyne Bouix ici
présente en entier
non attendez pierre non mais ça va
devenir chaud
je croyais pas capable de faire ça c'est
à dire que il le pauvre il est là il est
bon et vous le plaquer au mur dès le
premier soir
donc c'est vrai vous placomur et elle
vous embrasse elle vous embrasse comme
au cinéma et vous dites un vrai baiser
de voyou
comme ça et je l'ai écrasé
quel genre de cinéma parce que
et Arditi en plus à l'époque il était
avec quelqu'un
donc il dit que vous l'embrassez vous le
collez au mur et après il y a tout un
dégagement sur le baiser que c'est que
finalement on peut faire l'amour mais
tant qu'on embrasse pas on n'aime pas
vraiment que le baiser c'est le premier
le premier acte d'amour enfin délire
absolument vous souvenez bien évidemment
c'est comme un appartement si vous
embrassez pas vous aimez pas c'est quand
même pas
je ne sais pas c'est vrai je sais pas
comment vous comment ça se passe pour
vous mais pas moi personnellement je
vais vous montrer
c'est lamentable pierre voilà où on est
le service public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que là j'ai déjà un pull machin je
vais crever là non mais je le mettrai
en tous les cas à la lumière de cette
anecdote relatée dans Marie-Claire
incroyable c'est qu'en fait c'est un
petit peu dans votre vie quotidienne un
petit peu comme au cinéma non
non bon on va voir on va faire une
interview dans la vraie vie
aussi est-ce que dans la vraie vie il
vous arrive de vous jouer la comédie
l'un à l'autre bah non nous on a la
on a la comédie et on ouvre la porte de
la maison puis boum la comédie derrière
la maison vous êtes comment alors la
maison on a pas besoin de ça on fait
autre chose il joue mal à la maison
je t'aime maintenant je t'aime
vraiment naze est-ce que est-ce que dans
la vraie vie il vous arrive d'entendre
des applaudissements dans les moments de
tendresse ou juste après
oui pourquoi
il y a souvent des coups de théâtre dans
votre vie Évelyne
alors là c'est pas là
c'est pas lamentable là
j'essaye de transformer la vie tant que
faire ce peu en tout cas le quotidien
comme quelque chose qui est plus magique
et plus mystérieux et plus agréable et
plus rigolo tant que faire ce peu alors
ça c'est important est-ce que dans la
vraie vie vous faites relâche le lundi
pas du tout pas du tout non est-ce que
dans la vraie vie vous avez déjà trouvé
un amant dans le placard
non non donc c'est pas du tout du tout
du tout comme au théâtre finalement la
vraie vie pas vraiment non est-ce que
dans la vraie vie pierre il y a une
scène que vous ne vous laisserez jamais
de jouer avec Evelyne
il y en a plusieurs
bien sûr la cassette est-ce qu'il y a
une scène dans la vraie vie que vous
voulez plus jamais jouer avec Evelyne
il y a des scènes que je n'aimerais pas
avoir à jouer avec Evelyne quoi par
exemple
pour revenir à la question précédente il
y a des scènes que je rejouerai il a des
souvenirs je ne voulais je ne voulais
pas
vous en nourrirez
le parking l'anecdote du parking
en dehors de la chambre la loge et tout
ça quand elle vous a quoi d'autre
endroit
on était très voiture nous voilà
voilà
pour la revente et plutôt break ou la
voiture on a eu de très jolies retours
de tournage en voiture
[Musique]
je suis resté un message de la
prévention routière il faut pas inciter
les gens à baiser au volant parce que ça
peut être très dangereux nous n'étions
pas au volant alors allons-y mes enfants
Salomé vous êtes la fille de Claude
Lelouch et d'Évelyne Bouix
et vous avez grandi avec Pierre Arditi
qui était donc le mari d'Évelyne à ce
moment-là vous avez débuté au cinéma à
l'âge de 12 jours
pour commencer une carrière
votre mère savait ce que ça coûte de
quitter l'école trop tôt et elle vous a
interdit de le faire
c'est Pierre qui au moment où j'ai voulu
partir de l'école à 16 ans m'a dit NON
NON maintenant tu ramènes ton cul à
l'école et tu passes ton BAC
c'est un bon père c'est Pierre Arditi
quand même très bon est-ce qu'il est
dans l'intimité comme quand il vient
dans cette émission il dit toujours
c'est rentable voilà il le dit aussi bon
on pensait que ça nous était réservé
mais non bon il le dit tout le temps
Jean-Luc Reichmann
Jean-Luc Reichmann bonsoir bonsoir
donc quelques mails Jean-Luc avant de
commencer un mail d'Étienne Mouge
président de TF1 où vous animez tous les
jours attention à la marche à 12h05
Jean-Luc si tu fais plus de 30% de part
de marché sur les 15-35 chez hardi santé
viré il le dirait j'ai du fait 15% quand
même pendant un peu comme ça
et je suis sûr Étienne que nous les
ferons
Jean-Luc a été une voix des Guignols
donc effectivement c'est limité tout le
monde alors c'est vrai que Étienne
moujote lui-même n'arrive pas à savoir
qui est fontaine et qui bataille je ne
sais pas alors fontaine je ne boirai pas
de ton eau c'est vrai que le prochain
grand prime time de TF1 c'est les 100
meilleures émissions de best of des
meilleures émissions
bien sûr bien sûr
tiens Jean-Luc Reichmann vous avez
déclaré je voulais être Coluche mais
c'était déjà pris comme boulot c'est
vrai donc maintenant vous essayez de
prendre le boulot de Guy Lux non
non
j'ai animé jeu sans frontière c'est vrai
et c'est vrai une saison c'était un
bonheur et là je me suis sentie vraiment
gilux
chers amis bonsoir chers amis bonsoir et
bienvenue
allez Patrick retire ton masque
je finesse aussi
non non mais là
pour faire on n'est pas là pour faire
Patrick Sébastien on est déjà sur la 2
Patrick Sébastien
[Musique]
c'est qu'il fait très bien Serge
Gainsbourg c'est génial
alors Jean-Luc Reichmann vous avez
découvert votre don très tôt donc
puisque votre père était directeur de
supermarché et un jour c'est
l'anniversaire du magasin il vous met à
l'animation de la vente des saucisses si
vous faites un carton votre premier
carton quatre donne en 5 jours 4 tonnes
quand ça fait ça après tu es tranquille
alors vous faites vos débuts à la radio
en 81 en 87 vous venez à Paris alors
votre carrière bon il y a de la radio il
y a des voix off il y a plein de trucs
il y a du théâtre aussi d'ailleurs Jean
est venu c'est une des rares personnes
qui soit venue c'était une comédie
musicale rock et ta maman est venue
c'était les Précieuses ridicules de
Molière le texte était intégral mais
c'était en rock musical comédie et c'est
une des rares personnes elle était avec
elle fait un beau grain d'humour
mais les blondes mais ça va pas ou quoi
c'est ma sœur
parce que j'étais pas du tout au courant
pour du grain-beaubourg
bien donc voilà votre carrière les
Précieuses ridicules en rock'n'roll
entre autres des voix de la radio sur
les plus grandes chaînes de radio
nationale mais en fait vous devenez
célèbre Jean-Luc Reichmann dans
n'oubliez pas votre brosse à dents sa
dent et tout le monde en parle voilà et
c'est là où moi j'ai découvert Jean-Luc
Reichmann le deal en fait avec Nagui
c'était je viens faire ta voix off mais
je parle quand je veux celui qui m'a
laissé le micro ouvert un peu comme ma
fille ici quoi et ça a été ça a été
non mais moi je remercierai jamais assez
c'était quand même gonflé je te couperai
un montage ferme ta gueule
quand vous vouliez ça c'était un grand
bonheur bon il y avait l'homme qui fait
les sampleurs ici Didier drussan qui
était juste à ma gauche et on s'amusait
ouais
[Applaudissements]
mais [__]
et c'est un grand souvenir avec génial
Didier on s'en rappelle pas
si je pense sincèrement alors ensuite je
vais présenter les amours toujours sur
France 2 et alors là évidemment il y a
un truc il y a un truc énorme dans les
amours j'imagine qu'on vous en parle
toujours mais moi c'est un truc qui fait
le plus rire dans la vie c'était quel
est l'endroit le plus torride où vous
ayez fait l'amour donc le mari répond tu
connais la formule d'abord c'est le mari
qui répond la femme est cachée le mari
répond sur la table de la cuisine et la
femme répond
dans l'anus
extraordinaires il y a la bonne femme
qui voit son mec un jour à l'écran et
elle était partie sans laisser d'adresse
depuis 2 ans ça y est des histoires
extraordinaires
en fait à la production on soit un coup
de fil et dire enfin voilà bonjour
excusez-moi j'ai vu une personne que je
connais bien et que j'aimerais bien
rencontrer tout ça il est passé hier
dans notre émission en diffusion et tout
effectivement ils étaient en couple
Marie et femme et en fait c'était le
mari d'une femme qui avait disparu
depuis deux ans et le mec est venu sur
le plateau avec une autre femme
et
et on n'a jamais donné l'adresse mais
c'est c'est arrivé c'est arrivé il s'en
est passé des choses alors un jour
Jean-Luc Reichmann en 1999 on découvre à
l'antenne cette tâche de naissance sur
votre visage qui avait été jusque là
dissimulé
maintenant au laser il y a plein de il y
a plein de possibilités et je veux pas
l'enlever je suis né comme ça et
j'aimerais comme ça
j'ai fait du laser justement récemment
pour enlever un tatouage
et ça fait pas mal bonjour Luc vous
savez qui si on dit tout donc obligé de
tout passer en revue il y a eu aussi
votre petit dérapage vous en souvenez de
ça oui très bien raconter ou je le
raconte ah vous pouvez le raconter un
jour comme ça il y a quelqu'un qui gagne
et vous dites bravo ça fait trois youpi
pour Patrick et vous rajoutez non ça
fait trois youpas donc bon voilà c'est
le dérapage c'est le vous enfoncez après
vous dites j'espère que les Yoopa m'en
voudront pas c'est là où c'est devenu un
peu grave non mais pas du tout en fait
ce qui s'est ce qui se passe quand on
fait des jeux télé comme ça à l'échelle
vous le savez vous le savez je m'appelle
Reichmann avec deux ailes t'inquiète pas
tout va bien et donc quand on fait 50 ou
60 émissions les unes des autres on en
fait six quand on fait des jeux comme ça
je faisais les amours on en faisait 6
par jour j'étais fatigué j'en étais à la
55e ou 56e et il y a un jingle qui fait
et donc et donc j'enchaîne au niveau des
sonorités et c'était un très très
mauvais jeu de mots il s'avère que ils
ont oublié de le couper au montage et
c'est tout simple j'avais demandé qu'on
le coupe et cela n'a pas été coupé et
quand on est fatigué on peut faire des
dérapages et s'en est un je me suis
excusé je sais le lendemain et juste
pour la petite histoire c'est c'était
assez touchant pour moi parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une énorme unité et on en
dit et on en fait je me suis excusé à
juste avant mon émission le lendemain je
suis allé à la à la direction de la
Chaîne aujourd'hui excusez-moi c'est un
très mauvais jeu de mots je m'en excuse
pour de vrai je m'appelle Reichmann qui
plus est donc avec tous mes tous mes
ascendants et juste pour la petite
anecdote il y a un monsieur un jour qui
est arrivé lors d'une conférence de
presse et qui m'a dit j'ai vu ce que tu
as fait et tu es la seule personne qui a
eu le courage de faire ça avant une
émission le lendemain et et depuis je te
regarde totalement différemment et j'ai
beaucoup de respect depuis ce jour-là
pour Alain Delon parce que c'était Alain
Delon qui me l'a dit et il me dit mais
ils ont pas compris que tu t'appelais un
Reichmann et et j'étais très touché par
ce monsieur l'affaire est close alors
texte vous a remplacé aux amours mais
vous le trouvez comment très très sympa
[Applaudissements]
il sait très bien il est très bien dans
ce rôle là j'en ai présenté une et alors
ça m'a beaucoup amusé d'ailleurs de la
présence après ben parce qu'ils vont pas
voulu je sais pas j'étais pas assez bien
le micro d'un mandat
il est coincé
ah oui d'accord d'accord
on va faire le 18 à chaque fois Lolo et
là donc cher Jean-Luc Reichmann nous
inventé attention à la marche en fait
France 2 n'en veut pas et vous allez le
faire sur TF1 avec beaucoup de succès je
crois que c'était un non ça marche bien
ça marche bien alors l'émission est
basée sur des sondages étonnants par
exemple 27% des femmes aiment enlever
les points noirs de leur conjoint
combien de pour cent de 7%
étonné c'est qu'il y a c'était quoi la
question combien de personnes
sur 100 femmes combien de femmes ont
déjà dans leur vie déchiré les les
habits de leur homme voilà combien
combien tu dis toi
90 et en fait c'était 30 ans
ils sont dégueulasses alors il y en a
une autre c'est par exemple combien
d'hommes portent un string tous les
jours
à ton avis 14 %. non 1% excuse-moi tu
vois des mecs qui sont pas normaux là
non mais il y a des trucs très 9% des
Français pensent que les trains roulent
plus vite la nuit par exemple
extraordinaire mais je pense et ça aussi
je pensais que les trains de nuit ou les
plus vite bah oui il y avait personne
sur les voix
mettre un préservatif avec la bouche
tu sais le faire ça
68% des Français pensent qu'il faut pas
tout dire à leur conjoint
68% ça fait beaucoup quand même voilà et
vous pensez qu'il faut tout dire à son
conjoint
quand ça fait mal non je pense pas je
pense que effectivement on peut ne pas
tout dire non pas mentir mais pas tout
dire mais justement on va faire une
interview et vous genre
quand tu as fait des compliments tout à
l'heure on a chanté tes louanges essaye
de nous envoyer un jingle qui bave pas
comme ça donc
alors Jean-Luc Reichmann 10% des hommes
aiment les femmes au sein silicone et
vous
je dois vous avouer qu'aujourd'hui je
suis allé au salon de l'agriculture
j'aime bien la nature
8% des hommes ne portent pas de
sous-vêtements ce qui est mon cadre
d'ailleurs alors et vous vous portez le
sous-vêtement oui l'été de temps en
temps non 54% des Français se sont déjà
cogné la tête contre le mur en faisant
l'amour et vous je roule en deux roues
je porte un casque
19% des femmes ont déjà mesuré le sexe
de leur conjoint et vous
parce que je trouve ça extraordinaire
non moi je me suis jamais fait rien du
tout et vous avez mesuré
à ça bien sûr
quand j'étais étudiant à Montpellier oui
et il y a une femme qui est vous êtes
déjà mesuré à ça bien sûr bah oui
alors je suis maintenant chauffeur de
salle vous voulez savoir
je ne vous dirai qu'une chose je n'ai
pas avoir honte
et après bien sûr
85 % des hommes justement pense que leur
sexe est à la bonne taille et vous ah
ouais très bien
ah si ça c'est intéressant 16% des
hommes sont dérangés par les cris
excessifs de leur partenaire et vous ça
m'est arrivé une fois c'est horrible
hein
10% des Français font l'amour tous les
jours et vous ça m'a réconché en forme
tous les jours tous les jours
[Musique]
Romain Sardou ça va romain
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez reçu ici pour votre
premier roman qui s'appelle pardonner
nos offenses le livre venait de sortir
et depuis vous en avez vendu 280 000
exemplaires et c'est traduit dans 10
pays il est content votre père mon père
est très content c'est bien ah oui c'est
bien non
je pensais pas je me doutais qu'on
allait en parler évidemment ou qui
allait avoir un petit un petit coup de
projecteur dessus pour des raisons
externes à la littérature enfin bon pas
280 000 exemplaires parce qu'on est le
fils de Michel Sardou
je continue votre père dites-vous il a
plus d'imagination que le feu sacré oui
parce qu'on associe le feu sacré à la
scène plutôt donc ça ça m'a pas ça m'a
jamais vraiment alors vous savez que que
votre père l'a souvent invité dans cette
émission on a même eu son smoking en
vente bon il devait venir l'acheter il
est pas venu vous croyez qu'il nous en
veut mais j'en sais rien je vais lui
demander
derrière sa réponse j'en sais rien non
mais il fait pas beaucoup beaucoup de
télé il est pas
vous avez des nouvelles méfier de vous
un peu quand même vous avez des
nouvelles de lui ah bah tout le temps
bien sûr on va faire une interview vous
avez des nouvelles
[Musique]
est-ce que il regrette toujours le temps
béni des colonies le tobiner
c'est il jouait un personnage dans cette
chanson c'est pas parce que quand il
chante je suis pour il pense au string
pour homme je pense pas non
est-ce qu'il fait toujours l'amour en
chantant toujours
des soirées de son statut faire mais
c'est unique sur le store toujours la
gueule dans les balles populaires ou
bien il préfère Saint-Tropez maintenant
ah non il est plus belle populaire
Saint-Tropez il veut toujours pas qu'on
l'appelle France toujours
il aime toujours les ricains
une longue histoire mais non non il aime
les requins pour ce qu'ils ont fait pour
ce qu'ils ont fait comme tout le monde
on a complètement con pour dire tout
mélanger mais sur le sur le final
d'ailleurs il n'y va plus il est tout le
temps aux États-Unis il habite toujours
en France suffisamment la France c'est
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on dit non
c'est beaucoup encore ça il se corse
beaucoup ça doit être l'âge
est-ce que il pense aussi là quand il
dit elle court elle court la maladie de
l'amour il n'y pensait pas à l'époque en
tout cas c'était pas d'actualité pensez
qu'il viendra un jour dans cette
émission j'ai des doutes quand même ah
oui
je pense pas qu'il sera à l'aise dans ce
genre de mais bon je vais pas répondre à
sa place mais je pense pas c'est pas
trop son truc j'accueil
bonsoir bonsoir ça va ça va très bien
merci
tout va bien se passer
Cynthia de la première épouse de Michel
Sardou Françoise Pétré qui à l'époque
était danseuse au Châtelet vous êtes né
en 1973 en même temps que Romain Sardou
que nous avons reçu souvent ici alors à
l'époque où vous naissiez donc de
l'épouse de de Michel Sardou romain
essaie de Babette qu'à l'époque n'était
pas encore la femme n'était pas encore
la deuxième femme de Michel Sardou mais
était sa maîtresse et ça
alors Michel voulait un garçon et de
toute évidence c'était pas vous c'était
pas moi c'était pas moi et je pense que
bon je l'ai
comment expliquer ça j'étais une erreur
quoi oui je le pense sincèrement et j'ai
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas honte de ce que
j'ai écrit je n'ai pas honte de ce que
je suis aujourd'hui parce que je suis
une fille et je suis ravie d'être une
fille finalement parce que
voilà moi et alors votre mère vous en a
votre mère vous en a voulu en fait parce
qu'elle a elle a pensé elle s'est
imaginée que le fait que vous soyez une
fille à aider Michel à se séparer d'elle
en fait elle faisait un petit peu rendu
responsable on est persuadé on est
toujours persuadé aujourd'hui oui parce
que j'ai d'ailleurs il y a une lettre
qui me le prouve justement et que je que
je que j'intègre dans l'histoire donc
effectivement j'ai même 30 ans après
vous voyez c'est visiblement c'est resté
et vous donc vous avez grandi avec ce
sentiment de culpabilité c'est à dire
que vous sentiez un petit peu
responsable de leur rupture
je me suis complètement sentie
responsable de cette rupture déjà parce
que j'ai
pas vécu je peux pas dire que j'ai eu
une enfance parce que j'en ai pas eu mon
père à effectivement
donner ce qu'il fallait pour notre
éducation en revanche
moi je n'ai je ne me je ne me considère
pas avoir reçu l'éducation je me suis
éduqué toute seule je m'étais créé un
monde à moi dans ma tête un monde
merveilleux qui m'a permis de résister
absolument à tout c'est à dire dans mon
mental ces moments mental qui a fait que
j'ai résisté à toute la violence que que
j'ai
à l'époque où vous naissez Michel Sardou
est en train de devenir une méga vedette
vraiment une star nationale et en fait
vous décrivez l'envers du décor c'est à
dire que par exemple bon il est très
sympa comme ça que tu es avec des gens
et quand il est à la maison mais un
cendrier qui est déplacé il rentre dans
une colère noire il des regards
absolument terribles aux gens oui
effectivement enfin c'est oui il est il
est comme ça après son divorce Michel
Sardou épouse Babette donc ça la seconde
épouse et votre mère épouse dites-vous
un pseudo producteur de musique que vous
ne que vous ne citez pas vous donnez pas
son nom et lui il est intéressé en fait
par les relations de votre mère par le
carnet d'adresses de votre mère par
l'argent que votre père verse à votre
mère mais en fait vous l'appelez le
funeste d'ailleurs ça sera jamais
quelqu'un de positif pour vous en tous
les cas non jamais non je tiens à
préciser que pour moi il s'agit bien
d'un criminel en liberté c'est pas autre
chose c'est un personnage terrible parce
qu'il exige que vous l'appeliez papa
mais il vous bat et il vous battra
pendant des années en fait pendant j'ai
vécu dans cet entourage pendant plus de
15 ans ouais donc quand vous vivez ça
tous les jours effectivement c'est il y
a un moment il faut partir il faut s'en
aller
je dirais que ma mère était une absente
une absente avec un grand A et il y a
pas je pense que quand on aime quelqu'un
l'amour parfois peut aller si loin que
on en est on est aveugle de tout ce qui
se passe autour et je pense que oui
d'accepter ce qu'il vous faisait subir
en fait
peut-être
quand vous voyez Michel Sardou ça se
passe pas mieux parce que vous voyez
très peu mais quand vous voyez par
exemple une fois vous avez 5 ans il est
très dur avec vous vous un jour vous
refusez des d'évacuer la salle de bain
il vous traite de tas de merde quand
même quoi oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
j'avais 5 ans et je me rappelle c'est
d'ailleurs c'est
même étonnant mais la psychanalyse a
fait remonter encore des choses à la
surface parce qu'on croit toujours que
tout est enfoui et qu'on oublie mais en
fait c'est en soi c'est
et après ça il s'est pas excusé quoi
Michel Sardou s'excusera rarement
en général alors les bons moments
finalement c'est avec votre grand-mère
Jackie Sardou alors là ça se passe super
bien quoi c'est vraiment quelqu'un que
vous vous adorez qui vous donne beaucoup
oui qui a été très présente et
d'ailleurs même dans des contextes je
dirais
complètement loufoque parce qu'elle
était elle a mis le scandale dans un
restaurant un jour et c'était très drôle
finalement bon c'était une femme
exceptionnelle c'est une grande dame
c'est une grande comédienne parce que je
pense qu'on lui a pas rendu hommage
comme il aurait fallu le faire et
j'avais envie de le faire et ça me fait
bien plaisir
alors
ce qui est terrible pendant toute votre
enfance en fait c'est que le sujet
Michel Sardou chez vous est un tabou
c'est-à-dire que on en parle pas sauf
pour dire que c'est un abruti ou alors
quand il passe à la télé en zap donc en
plus vous vivez dans le déni de votre
père pendant toute votre enfance et
votre adolescence oui je veux dire on
était on nous a fait aussi du bourrage
de crâne pendant très longtemps et ça je
le il faut être il faut le dire aussi et
donc effectivement quand vous avez du
bourrage de crâne pendant tout ce temps
vous il est c'est normal qu'elle a au
bout du compte vous vous disiez bon bah
ok ben non quoi c'est c'est
effectivement ça peut
ça
gâche les relations quoi qu'il arrive
en commençant que votre livre était
extrêmement bouleversant parce que vous
vivez finalement dans cette maison où on
critique votre père sans arrêt quand
vous voyez votre père et vous traite de
tas de merde et pour vos 12 ans votre
beau-père vous vous carrément vous êtes
complètement recroquevillé tout ça donc
à un moment évidemment on est on a c'est
très bouleversant cette histoire on
souffre pour vous quand vous êtes dans
l'incapacité de bouger et quand vous
effectivement vous êtes au sol et que
vous pouvez pas bouger pendant un temps
la seule larme qui vous reste c'est
votre esprit et c'est ce qui s'est
produit également dans la tentative de
meurtre c'est-à-dire que votre mental
quand je vous il reste que ça pour
finalement trouver pour garder et pour
rester en vie c'est un instinct de
survie parce que votre beau-père il vous
bat parce que vous recevez des copines
en pantoufle par exemple
moi je me suis demandé sincèrement ce
que je faisais là et je veux dire
j'avais rien à faire là et c'est logique
vous partez à un moment donné parce que
il y a pas il y a rien à faire il y a
rien à justement Cynthia quand vous
partez pour pour faire des études tout
ça vous vous apercevez qu'en fait le
fric que Michel Sardou donne à votre
mère votre beau-père le garde pour lui
donc en plus et même pas les moyens de
faire des études enfin vous êtes
complètement bloqué vous avez des
monsieur faire une année si parce que
j'ai voulu le faire j'ai travaillé pour
ça et j'ai travaillé pour payer mes
études effectivement même si c'était pas
énorme j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu tout
simplement
[Musique]
c'est vrai et malgré tout un moment où
vous pensez à vous suicider quand même
oui effectivement et c'est un cloche
un alcoolique mais sauve la vie c'est
formidable c'est formidable alors vous
commencez à vous en sortir vous
commencez à bosser Jackie Sardou vous
faire entrer chez Daniel Philippe Paqui
comme maître d'hôtel le dessin
boulot des petits jobs vous commencez à
vous intégrer à la société vous
commencez à exister vous travaillez à i
télévision donc qui est une filiale info
du groupe Canal+ et là un soir voilà
vous quittez vous quittez itélévision
vous rentrez chez vous et dans le
parking de votre immeuble vous êtes
carrément enlevé par trois mecs
j'ai été enlevé dans ma voiture oui
trois mecs qui vont vous violer pendant
pendant deux heures
séquestrer avec un couteau bien sûr
enfin couteau est pas loin en tout cas
et puis bon bah j'ai en plus je sais
même pas où on en mène je sais pas ce
qui va m'arriver effectivement on peut
s'attendre à tout parce que quand on
voit les visages le visage d'un criminel
et qu'on peut le reconnaître
effectivement
d'ailleurs j'étais à deux doigts
d'exploser dans mon auto donc oui
c'était alors à ce moment là votre mec
vous lâche mais à un moment Sardou pour
vous rejoindre à ce moment-là un
accrochage dans le tunnel de la défense
il se brise la mâchoire c'est vraiment
un enchaînement de de choses absolument
terrible et et vous vous trouvez refuge
en fait chez Michel Sardou qui vient de
se remarier donc pour la pour la
troisième fois avec Anne-Marie Périer
vous commencez à vivre un peu chez eux
c'est lui qui vous le propose en fait
et au bout d'un moment il vous le
reproche
oui effectivement il y a un juste un
mois tout juste après les faits j'avais
quand même dans le sang
un traitement de VIH qui est quand même
difficile à supporter parce qu'en plus
j'ai repris le travail 10 jours après et
je suis retourné à la chaîne j'ai très
bon j'étais en traitement thérapeutique
et effectivement j'avais toujours dans
ma tête je me demandais si j'allais
avoir le sida ou pas et effectivement je
oui j'étais donc je travaillais à la
chaîne je rentrais le soir et tout ça et
puis effectivement il y a il y a un
matin j'ai été j'ai eu effectivement une
engueulade avec mon père en privé et
j'ai
on m'a foutu dehors quoi on m'a foutu
son appartement mais sa femme et puis en
tout cas pire que tout c'est qu'il vous
dit que vous mangez du poisson et que ça
lui coûte plus cher que la viande ça
j'avoue que ça m'a complètement mangé de
viande c'est impossible pour moi je ne
pouvais pas parce que suite aux fait
c'était impossible et parce que je
ne me forçais pas je et je me suis
forcée en plus de ça parce qu'il m'a
quand même fait manger de la viande je
ne le dis pas mais c'est pas grave
alors il vous dit que vous êtes nul que
votre thérapie c'est de la merde enfin
vraiment on peut pas dire qui qui vous
aide et ce qui est extraordinaire dans
cette histoire c'est qu'en fait vous en
auriez pas parlé on l'aurait jamais su
s'il y a que tous les journaux tous les
magazines français les radios les
télévisions ont accepté de de pas parler
de de votre de votre violence et alors
lui en fait il va pas au procès
justement pour pas qu'on en parle
j'imagine je ne demandais pas à ce qu'il
soit là parce qu'effectivement la presse
aurait pu attirer il aurait pu attirer
l'attention de la presse justement en
revanche un coup de téléphone ou un
petit mot gentil avec un bouquet de
fleurs ça fait de mal à personne
alors vous agresseurs sont condamnés à
15 13 et 10 ans de prison ce qui est
plutôt
plutôt bien non plutôt pas mal mais
alors votre père qui a toujours parlé de
faire justice lui-même qui a toujours
dit qu'il était pour la peine de mort il
a laissé la justice faire son travail
sans intervenir sur ce coup-là
effectivement
alors quelles ont été les réactions de
Michel Sardou à votre livre il a eu une
très bonne réaction il a très bien réagi
à ça et c'est plutôt agréable à entendre
et je suis ravie
j'en sais rien il a dit qu'il reconnaits
qu'il avait pas été un bon père d'une
certaine façon quoi
est-ce que vous pensez pas que Michel
Sardou c'est comporté comme ça avec vous
parce que lui aussi a été finalement il
a pas eu ses parents il était en pension
mon sel il voyait rarement son père
rarement sa mère et peut-être ça l'a pas
habitué à être un bon père une certaine
façon non c'est pas je lui en veux même
pas d'avoir été absent c'est marrant moi
je parce que je
je n'en veux pas d'avoir été absent
parce qu'un artiste déjà ne se comporte
pas comme quelqu'un de normal c'est pas
quelqu'un de normal un artiste un
artiste c'est quelqu'un a pas d'appare
différent des autres qui est qui restent
dans une
qui qui est solitaire et donc je ne lui
en veux pas de d'avoir été absent parce
que je sais qu'il a donné ce qu'il
fallait donc je lui en veux pas pour ça
d'ailleurs je lui en veux pour rien moi
je suis parti et je j'avais des raisons
très personnelles de le faire et
d'ailleurs j'ai écrit ce témoignage
parce que j'ai eu d'autres pressions aux
États-Unis et que j'en ai eu assez
quelle pression vous avez aux États-Unis
parce que j'avais écrit ce témoignage au
départ pour moi et j'en ai eu assez de
supporter parce que tout ça ça fait
remonter la peur et mon passé et j'en ai
eu assez je me suis dit que les gens
avaient le droit de savoir
Michel Sardou
je l'ai vu il y a 2 ans et demi c'était
juste avant mon départ aux États-Unis
au théâtre
que j'ai d'ailleurs je le cidre et vous
a téléphoné depuis l'apparition du livre
non
vous pensez que ce livre va aider ou
aggraver votre relation avec lui déjà il
y a pas de relation pour l'instant donc
il y a pas de dialogue effectivement et
d'ailleurs je ne cherche pas en avoir
moi j'ai fait un choix je suis parti
parce que c'était la seule façon de m'en
sortir
maintenant je vous dis sincèrement que
si je continue à être embêté là-bas et
si on continue
bon je vais pas non plus pousser loin
les pressions mais j'irai jusqu'au bout
vous regrettez pas de pas lui avoir dit
tout ça de vive voix plutôt qu'à travers
un livre à votre père
j'ai ce faire plusieurs fois et
ça il y a pas de dialogue le dialogue ne
passe pas je les aime mes parents je les
renie pas je renie personne sauf que il
y a un moment il y a il se passe rien
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire je veux
dire il y a pas il y a pas d'issue vous
pouvez pas changer les gens monsieur le
ministre le mot de la fin non je suis un
peu un peu gêné pardon de vous le dire
parce que je crois que dans les affaires
privées vraiment quand il s'agit de la
vie des couples la vie amoureuse des
gens la vie affective avec ses parents
personne non seulement ne peut juger
mais personne n'a le droit de juger on
peut pas dire qu'on dise des vérités il
y a pas de vérité dans ses affaires là
quand des gens séparent quand des gens
se fâchent entre parents enfants entre
si proche que ça entre Marie et femme
personne n'a le droit ni le pouvoir de
savoir ce qui s'est passé vraiment et
donc je suis au fond ce que vous dites
là il faut probablement c'est à lui que
vous le dites d'ailleurs mais faut le
dire votre père peut-être à votre
analyse mais au fond je suis pas sûr
qu'il y ait vraiment du courage à le
publier en plus je suis pas sûr sont bon
pour vous voilà mais bon il faudrait en
parler un peu plus longuement mais dans
ces affaires là ne croyez pas que
personne ne pense qu'on puisse dire ah
il est mauvais il a tort il a raison ou
la pauvre ou le méchant on peut jamais
savoir comment ça se passe peut-être que
ce que vous dites est entièrement vrai
mais de toute façon moi je ne le saurai
jamais personne ici ne pourra jamais
juger et donc peut-être sont des choses
qu'il faut le dire à lui mais pas mais
pas aux autres et donc je fais toujours
un peu gêné quand la sphère privée
s'étale en public alors que bon voilà
vous livrez ça au chien si je puis dire
à des gens qui vont dire du mal de lui
dire c'est un [__] mais personne n'en
saura jamais rien oui mais c'est votre
affaire c'est avec lui si vous voulez il
faut régler ça avec son père mais pas
avec les autres Sardou est très
secondaire dans mon histoire quand même
si c'était pas lui on en parlerait pas
ici
simplement que j'ai vraiment peur qu'en
passant du très privé comme ça au public
vous soyez extrêmement déçu après parce
que le jugement des autres a
probablement aucun rapport avec ce que
vous avez vécu en tout cas n'a pas deux
qui comprennent forcément ce que vous
disiez ou qui puisse être juge en
affaire c'est vrai que quand on écrit un
livre et qu'on le déchire pas après
c'est quand même qu'on a besoin de des
autres pour comprendre ou pour juger
est-ce qu'on a vécu et quand c'est des
affaires très privé je crois on risque
d'être de se tromper d'être déçu voilà
c'est ce cas ça que je voulais vous dire
surtout mais pas ces points méchanceté
vous répondre simplement que le crime
n'a pas de visage et que quel que soit
le contexte social ou que vous soyez le
crime arrive n'importe où n'importe
quand et qu'il n'y a pas de lieu et en
revanche il y a pas de
tout peut arriver dans une existence
tout est possible et rien n'est
impossible dans le corps d'une existence
et c'est ça le message
et maintenant voici Marilyn Manson
je voulais qu'on fasse rentrer mon
invité surprise
c'est une réaction par rapport à
certains emails qu'on a reçu c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas des puristes on n'est
pas forcément des linguistes mais des
gens qui sont irrités derrière leur
poste parce qu'ils nous arrivent parfois
de faire surtout à toi qui risque moi je
suis pas là très souvent il nous arrive
de faire des fautes de France donc j'ai
invité Yoda mon maître il va être là
juste pour contrôler que les tendeurs
maître cabelo dans un cliquez surprise
de Laurent baby jusqu'à la bonsoir
heureux de vous voir et réussit
franchement merci broquement mais la
dernière fois que je vous ai vu c'était
au Folies Bergères on faisait double jeu
et on avait fumé un pétard ensemble
et après l'émission
alors moi ça m'étonne pas du tout hein
alors simplement mettre Capello et là
pour un peu superviser la bonne tenue
les belles constructions de phrases et
puis faire la chasse la chasse au
barbarisme
et au foot en général d'accord merci
d'accord d'ailleurs je vous soutiens des
grands ceux vont vous reprocher le 23
avril sans liaison c'est vous qui avez
raison pourquoi parce que vous dites
trois avenues la liaison mais dans 3
avril je te remercie
donc
oh d'accord passe une bonne idée
déchirer ces lettres de mécontents il a
arrêté la dose apparemment vous avez
arrêté les
joint d'accord très bien maître bien
vous restez avec nous donc
restez chez toutes les semaines bien tu
vas voir à quel point il est précieux
donc je vais être un petit peu la
dompteuse d'homme c'est à dire que cette
innocence
OK
la fille décide de vraiment de venir une
vous savez de quoi je parle quand même
bah c'est c'est rien on collectionne ah
d'accord pour montrer qu'on s'en fout
quoi non pas du tout
le fait que je maîtrise les Raquin et
l'arabe peut en tout cas aider beaucoup
d'associations humanitaires
il se remet en marche tout seul
répétant très bien merci
ça a gagné
c'est entre les deux fleuves parce que
maison c'est le milieu potamo c'est le
club c'est entre le Tigre et le Frat
trop fort
c'est le service public bon
l'hypotolanus un resto
c'est bien connu
le billon nombre non veut dire le petit
alors il est grand elle est bien ça veut
dire le petit vieux génial
c'est normal
c'est du Gaulois
[Musique]
alors Samuel avant de parler du film qui
vous amène ici je voudrais qu'on
revienne quelques instants à la case
départ qu'on fasse une espèce de de et
pas un espèce mais je sais maintenant
une espèce de
tomber dans le pied
c'est un peu compliqué ce soir
[Applaudissements]
Marilyn Manson
bonsoir fais gaffe
bonsoir Marilyn donc vous appelez
Maryline comme Monroe et Manson comme
Charles Manson ça vous est venu comment
cette idée d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur
en série sataniste avec le prénom du
Nikon glamour de l'Amérique
de l'Amérique votre surnom c'est
antéchrist superstar cela c'est bien
qu'est-ce qu'on pensait
superstar c'était le nom d'ailleurs
est assurée voilà et Maryline Manson est
une star donc du choc rock ce qu'on peut
appeler le choc rock alors dans la
tradition de des Stones avec Sympathy
for the devil ensuite les Black Sabbath
avec Ozzy Osborn Alice Cooper les Sex
Pistols je suis anarchiste je suis
l'Antéchrist chanté Johnny Rotten alors
on est très content de vous avoir ce
soir parce que vous êtes une star
mondiale Maryline Justine qui vient de
tomber beaucoup de gens en règle leur
téléviseur tout ça est normal
peut-être que les gens croient qu'il
regarde deux chaînes à la fois une
chaîne où il y aurait mètre Capello une
chaîne pas du tout c'est la même chaîne
c'est France 2 bien on va commencer par
le début marine Manson vous êtes né le 5
janvier 69 et votre vrai nom c'est Bryan
you Warner
votre père était un ancien mécanicien
d'hélicoptère au Vietnam
mais je me trompe jamais moi également
il gérait une magasin de meubles
et les seuls moments d'intimité de votre
père avec vous c'était quand il vous
emmenait au stand de tir pour vous
apprendre à tirer ça c'était un vrai
moment d'intimité avec lui et puis aussi
il vous emmenait au concert de Kiss
et mon père avait justement un
maquillage qui c'est même concert dans
cette tenue mon papa était cool alors ça
c'est votre papa votre maman c'est
l'inverse elle était très très
possessive très très étouffante comme ça
et quand vous êtes petit Marilyn Manson
vous passez beaucoup de temps chez vos
grands-parents et vous découvrez la
sexualité dans la cave de votre
grand-père voilà alors dans la cave du
grand-père ça te plaît ça te gêne ah là
là dans la cave du grand-père de Marilyn
il y avait quoi Maître Capello dans la
cave du grand-père de My Manson il y
avait des lingerie il y avait il y avait
des lingerie féminines il y avait des
godemichet enduit de vaseline les
godemichets
et puis il y a aussi des photos
zoophiles hein
[Applaudissements]
drôle de grand-père
quand j'étais gamin mon grand-père me
paraissait monstrueux mais en
grandissant je me sens rendu compte que
mon grand-père était bah je suis comme
lui donc il est pas si mal que ça
disons que j'aime pas trop les animaux
il fallait
la zoophilie
[Rires]
j'aime pouvoir rire son père alors donc
vous allez à l'école l'héritage
Christian School et là évidemment on
vous invite pardon parce qu'il a aussi
agrégé d'anglais
de cap merci mais en plus donc voilà
vous allez dans cette école donc on vous
inculque des valeurs fondées sur
l'Antéchrist et sur l'Apocalypse alors
évidemment ça tout ça ça travaille dans
votre tête vous essayez de vous adapter
à l'école vous essayez de vous adapter
et un jour vous leur apportez
une photo c'est des nuages dans le ciel
qui représentent un ange et lui il pense
qu'il pense là vous pensez leur faire
plaisir malgré moi c'était ma grand-mère
qui m'avait donné de cette image ils
m'ont dit que c'était un faux et donc
la seule fois où j'essaie de m'intégrer
vraiment dans ce milieu qu'on m'a dit
tout ça c'était du bidon ben j'ai arrêté
j'ai arrêté de de croire ou d'essayer de
croire à ce qu'on me racontait et alors
au lieu de vivre dans la peur d'avoir
des cauchemars j'ai décidé de devenir ce
dont j'avais peur jusqu'à voilà alors là
c'est la révolte dès l'âge de 12 ans
vous vous révoltez et vous êtes attiré
par tout ce qui est interdit vous êtes à
l'époque vous êtes maigre vous êtes
couvert de boutons vous êtes toujours
tout seul enfin vous avez une
adolescence ça c'est assez terrible non
moi je me sentais invisible transparent
c'était pas que j'étais rejeté j'étais
vraiment invisible on ne me voyait pas
et ça n'est qu'à travers la musique ou
l'écriture quand j'étais gamin je me
suis dit que je serai artiste ou
écrivain je pense pas que j'ai chanté
parce que je savais pas chanter mais bon
et c'est comme ça que j'ai trouvé ma
propre voix je crée mon monde et alors
là en compagnie d'un certain John
Crowell et de son grand frère au lycée
vous commencez à vous intéresser aux
sciences
occultes
occultes occultes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sujet de votre cinquième album sur le
précédent vous avez déclaré c'est
l'histoire d'un innocent qui veut faire
partie d'un monde qui ne l'accepte pas
il se bat il découvre sa révolution et
finit par devenir un objet marketing
aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu un objet
marketing
et d'en faire
disons une marchandise il y a l'affaire
donc de Columbine donc c'est université
du Michigan ou deux femmes ouvrent le
feu sur leur camarades et les médias
américains vous accusent alors vous
répondez on peut pas accuser Shakespeare
de pousser les gens en suicide parce
qu'il a écrit Roméo et Juliette enfin
c'est vrai quand même que les gens qui
ont tiré sur leurs camarades étaient des
fans de Marilyn Manson
en fait il fallait un coupable donc on
m'a brandit un peu comme étant cette
effigie du coupable et j'ai décidé de ne
pas répondre à tout cela parce que je ne
voulais pas justement me mêler alimenter
cette flamme les gamins voulaient
justement acquérir une espèce de
célébrité malsaine l'Amérique aura donné
justement ce qu'ils recherchait et je
voulais pas y contribuer donc on a
associer le nom Marilyn Manson à cette
horreur et en fait Marilyn Manson est
devenu le produit de Columbine c'était
ironique mais en fait c'est quand même
assez injuste d'être attaqué par mon
propre pays
il n'a pas traduit vêtement par
actuellement mais en fait voilà la
finesse
vous dites que cette histoire finalement
permettait d'oublier Monica Lewinsky
parce qu'à l'époque c'était le grand
scandale de Monica Lewinsky on oublie
aussi grâce à ça les bombes balancées
sur le Kosovo et vous dites c'est moi
qu'on accuse de provoquer un
comportement violent alors que
finalement à la même époque les
Etats-Unis bombardaient la Yougoslavie
exactement
c'est à dire qu'on va continuer à
censurer mes mots ou mes images ou ma
musique
du gouvernement et moi mon rôle c'est
justement de mettre cette démarche au
défi il faut que moi si l'Amérique
représente la démocratie moi je dois
représenter la liberté d'expression ce
n'est pas quelqu'un comme moi il y
aurait personne justement pour remettre
en cause les fausses idées quitte à moi
qui convient le rôle justement de
remettre en cause certaines politiques
certaines valeurs ce qui ne veut pas
dire je déteste la mairie je l'accepte
pour ce qu'elle est et mon rôle c'est
d'en faire un pays plus intéressant plus
divertissement en étant beau gosse
d'accord alors
dans le film quand Michael Moore vous
pose la question et vous dit qu'est-ce
que vous diriez au lycéen de Columbine
et vous répondez je les écouterai ce que
personne ne fait
et c'est quelque chose que je dis depuis
le départ avant l'incident de Columbine
c'était pas la première fois qu'une
telle tragédie se produit c'est pas moi
qui a inventé la violence et c'est pas
non plus les gamins de Columbine ont
inventé la violence l'humanité à cette
tendance une tradition de s'autodétruire
et ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours évoqué dans ma musique alors
c'est comme la sécurité qu'on me montre
du doigt parce que tout ce que je dis
tout ce que je chante c'est un
commentaire sur cette triste réalité et
il est vachement sage hein
ça se voit un peu
et maintenant
voici Mike Horn
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
donc Michael est ce qu'on appelle un
aventurier de l'extrême c'est un type
extraordinaire la preuve il a déjà
descendu l'amazone à la nage il a fait
le tour du monde en suivant la ligne de
l'équateur et là
et là vous venez de faire 20000 km
autour du cercle polaire hardclic c'est
la fameuse expédition arctos alors vous
racontez ça dans un bouquin qui est
publié chez XO qui s'appelle conquérant
de l'impossible alors au départ vous
êtes d'origine hollandaise c'est des
Hollandais qui sont partis habiter en
Afrique du Sud français et Hollande et
hollandais
mais pas dans les mêmes coins mais bon
alors votre père était directeur de
lycée c'était un ex Springbox il est
mort quand vous aviez 15 ans et votre
mère était enseignante alors enfant vous
étiez déjà très sportif Mike Horn et son
avenir de d'aventurier se dessine assez
tôt à 8 ans vous rejoignez en vélo la
ferme de votre oncle qui est située à
300 km de la 300 km c'est pas loin
[Rires]
j'ai commencé la drogue tôt alors
quand vous étiez adolescent vous êtes
rentré dans dans l'armée vous avez été
capitaine des forces spéciales
sud-africaines j'ai fait la guerre en
Namibie donc ça vous a effectivement
formé à la violence voilà et puis
ensuite vous rentrez dans la vie
professionnelle et là Mike corne est
employé par son oncle il fait de
l'import-export de fruits et légumes au
départ d'ailleurs vous réalisez une
transaction exceptionnelle sur des choux
qui vous a rapporté énormément d'argent
j'ai trop vite trop bien à gagner ma vie
mais voilà ça lui plaisait pas parce que
bon il avait plein de blé mais il avait
pas de but dans la vie et là vous
établissez
[Rires]
dans la vie
donc là vous établissez une liste des
endroits de la jungle et des étendues
glacés vous aimeriez aller et puis vous
réunissez tous vos amis un jour
ouais j'ai eu tout ce que je voulais
je dis mais c'était pas ça que je
voulais et puis je disais mais ce soir
je fais un grand fait de chez moi et
puis je viens d'acheter à Johannesburg
un grand maison il y avait une piscine
et tout je disais à mes potes écoute
viens et puis ce soir je donne tout ce
que j'ai à toutes mes potes et puis on a
bu un peu d'hiver et tout ça ma soeur et
avec avocate et la préparer toutes les
contrats j'ai donné tout à mes amis et
puis je me retrouvais avec comme ça à
l'aéroport il a tout donné alors à ce
moment-là
à ce moment là elle va non mais c'est
extraire et les seuls pays en fait on
pouvait aller quand on était africains
du Sud sans visa c'était Israël la
Suisse et l'Angleterre donc il va à
l'aéroport à ce moment là il y a un
avion qui part pour la Suisse c'est
comme ça que vous vous retrouvez à
Zurich exactement sans sans rien
connaître de la langue sans rien
connaître du pays alors au début c'était
difficile quand même vous avez des
commencé il y a il y a 360 km entre
Zurich et Montreux et puis parce que
j'ai pas eu du travail et puis j'ai pas
eu de l'argent j'ai décidé de faire ça à
pied et puis de passer un peu vers les
paysans pour demander s'il y avait du
travail puis c'était toujours un peu la
même réponse Kahina
un peu il disait que quoi on engage pas
des étrangers et puis là je disais
d'accord écoute
je continue j'arrivais j'arrivais à
Montereau j'ai commencé de voler juste
pour rester vivant vous avez voulu des
fruits hein
j'ai dormi sous des ponts enfin c'est
incroyable parce que il y a quelque
chose d'extraordinaire c'est-à-dire
qu'en Afrique du Sud vous faisiez partie
de la la classe des possédants la classe
des riches des blancs à l'époque hein
c'était bon c'est encore là et puis un
jour vous arrivez en Suisse et vous
retrouvez dans la position du noir quoi
dans la position du du type cap adblay
ouais mais écoute c'est sûr c'est c'est
sûr que si tu te trouves dans la
situation un peu que t'as pas vraiment
l'habitude tu dis soit tu rentres à la
maison mais parce que j'ai eu rien à la
maison je dis il faut que j'arrête mes
responsabilités vous aviez comme on dit
brûler vos vaisseaux c'est à dire que
vous n'aviez plus de maison dans
laquelle retourner donc vous étiez
obligé de continuer vous faites des
petits boulots vous installez ensuite
vous rencontrez Cathy qui deviendra
votre votre femme vous commencez à
trouver des sponsors enfin c'est un
courage absolument extraordinaire et là
vous vivez votre première grande
aventure en 1997 traversée de l'Amérique
du Sud il part du Pérou il fait déjà 600
bornes à travers la Cordillère des Andes
mais comme ça tu vois comment il fait
pour y aller au Pérou en avion ouais
j'ai une copain qui était pilote et puis
donc il va au Pérou il fait 600 bornes
dans la Cordillère des Andes jusqu'au
source de l'Amazone et là vous descendez
l'Amazone
il avait un truc qui s'appelle
l'hydrospeed c'est une petite planche tu
sais un peu comme on disait comme ça
parce que tu peux pas vers vraiment
faire pipi dans l'eau parce qu'il y a
c'est une poisson de chat parasite dès
que tu fais pipi en fait la urine ça
l'attire et ça arrange
il y a un trou
et puis en fait tu peux pisser dans
l'eau mais il faut regarder ton pantalon
c'est comme tu fais chier sur la Place
Rouge
donc il fait quand même 600 il fait
quand même 6400 km à la nage donc avec
son hydrospeed pour descendre l'Amazone
jusqu'à l'embouchure de la zone dans
l'océan dans l'océan Atlantique première
aventure du mois
deuxième grande aventure qui a encore un
exploit absolument unique le tour du
monde en solitaire par l'équateur son
véhicule à moteur à l'idée c'était de
rester sur l'équateur et pas de
m'éloigner plus que 30000 euros 30 000
au sud et puis de partie des Gabon et
quand vous quittez le Gabon c'est la
première fois que vous vous retrouvez
seul sur un voilier j'ai jamais fait la
voile en fait j'ai wincher en fait sur
du bateau de Laurent Borgnon
pour traverser l'Atlantique c'est la
première fois qu'il est seul sur un
voilier
alors ensuite bon il y a il y a
l'Amérique du Sud vous traversez
l'Amérique du Sud l'Indonésie avec les
révoltes avec les combats tout ça
faisait extraordinaire et puis bon voilà
vous êtes élu aventuriers du 20e siècle
quand même ouais pas il y avait personne
d'autre c'est quoi c'est pour ça c'est
ça
les modes sont super bien alors bon on a
vu donc la descente de l'Amazon à la
nage le tour du monde par l'équateur et
là en février 2002 c'est arctose donc
c'est la dernière expédition celle que
vous racontez dans dans votre bouquin
conquérant de l'impossible donc 20000 km
autour du cercle polaire arctique à
contre-courant et à contrevent alors on
lui dit mais pourquoi quand on fait
20000 km autour du cercle polaire
arctique pourquoi vous le faites à
contre-courant à contrebande
[Applaudissements]
et alors quand on lui dit pourquoi vous
le faites à contre-courant à autrement
il dit bah parce que en cas de réussite
dans l'autre sens j'aurais passé toute
ma vie à me demander comment j'aurais
réussi dans le mauvais sens
contre contre des aliments que d'aller
avec les amis
c'est tellement dur ce qui fait que
il trouve le courage de surmonter toutes
les épreuves et vous dites je les ai
surmontés parce que j'ignorais quelle
souffrance elle représentait si j'avais
su quelle souffrance j'allais vivre
j'aurais pas fait vous utilisez des
accessoires aussi à la maison
ça continue
il y a des moments qui est plus durs que
les autres mais aujourd'hui c'est mon
métier et puis je fais ça
professionnellement pendant 10 ans et
puis c'est moi je vois ça comme tout à
fait normal en fait les courses vous
prenez un caddie vous mettez tout comme
ça sur le bureau
alors ce qu'il faut savoir quand même
c'est qu'avant de faire le tour du
cercle arctique voilà il est à l'envers
il y a eu un voyage préparatoire le
voyage préparatoire il dit bon pour me
préparer c'est pour se mettre en forme
je vais aller au Pôle Nord en solitaire
800 bornes
on s'entraîner
entraîner et là grosse erreur j'ai pas
vraiment le choix c'était un moment que
je marchais plus ça veut dire que mon
corps génère plus de chaleur et puis je
commence de tomber dans l'hypothermie et
puis là c'est c'est la vie au Ligue 1
j'ai enlevé mes moves pour attacher mes
chaussures voilà et puis c'est sûr c'est
la dernière fois que je m'en devais mes
moves
et alors ce qui fait il rentre dans sa
tente et il met ses doigts dans le feu
parce qu'ils sont tellement gelés qu'il
les met dans le feu et et à ce moment-là
oui il a eu il a été un peu amputé oui
et à ce moment-là ça sent la viande
brûlée lui sans rien mais ça sent ça
sent la viande brûlée alors
effectivement là vous décidez de rentrer
donc cette expédition préparatoire n'a
pas été menée à son terme vous décidez
de rentrer pour sauver vos mains en fait
c'est ça exactement et à un moment que
tu dises mais là maintenant je dois
rentrer je dois réparer mes mains
autrement si je continue j'étais à 15
jours du pôle si je continue je veux
perdre mes mains et puis je peux plus
rien faire de ma vie parce que tu avais
des lacets il fallait mettre des velcro
là
- 50 ça pète en fait
extraordinaire c'est que donc vous
rentrez on vous a plu un peu le le bout
des doigts mais vous attendez même pas
le délai normal vous partez pour cette
fameuse expédition donc à cause et là il
y a des épreuves absolument inouïe je
veux dire c'est par exemple à un moment
il va en bateau au départ de de Norvège
au Groenland il y a un trou dans dans la
coque et là alors là c'est incroyable
c'est que d'une maille conduit le bateau
de l'autre il vide le bateau et il y a
les icebergs qui arrivent sur lui le mec
il est au milieu
et là il y a Céline Dion qui se battre
et il se dit non
c'est incroyable
il se dit je peux pas dormir parce que
s'il dort bah il peut plus piloter le
bateau il peut plus vider le bateau donc
voilà et puis au milieu des icebergs
comme ça des fois un peu on a pas
vraiment les choix des fois et puis si
on va arriver en Greenland il faut c'est
vraiment un fou c'est vraiment cool
alors après il traverse le Groenland
donc il arrive au Groenland avec une
espèce de de cerf-volant quoi et ça va
très vite parce que vous arrivez à faire
des un jour par exemple il fait 18
heures dans la journée 143 km donc ça va
assez vite vous battez le record de
traverser du Groenland grâce à ce
système de cerf-volant et puis un jour
il y a un vent énorme looping voilà
ouais vous êtes vous êtes arraché vous
êtes arraché par une tempête devant
exactement là c'était justement que tu
peux plus gérer la surface est trop
grande mètre carré devant surface
70 km à l'heure et tu peux plus
descendre ta voile c'est sûr qu'il y a
un moment que tu vas passer dans une
cravate tu vas passer d'un peu de
professeur
tu tombes une chanson à chaque fois
c'est extraordinaire à un moment il
arrive dans une région il doit prendre
un bateau pour aller à Calamity beige je
crois il doit prendre un bateau et puis
bon il y a la glace qui fait qu'on peut
pas naviguer il fait un détour de 1200
km le mec le mec j'ai pris un détour de
300 m faire une histoire de 1200 km et
tout ça à moins 60 dans la nuit
permanente parce qu'en plus de ça il
faut voir ce que c'est il fait même pas
jour il neige il fait froid moins 60 il
fait nuit voilà malheureusement on a
trois mois de nuit ou n'a pas beaucoup
de soleil au nord et puis dès que du
soleil sors
24 heures sur 24 et puis là tu peux bien
avancer alors c'est extraordinaire parce
que ce sont des des régions où la vie
humaine est impossible c'est-à-dire que
les seuls qui vivent là-bas ce sont les
Inuits mais eux juge pas il reste tu
vois ils vivent sur leur graisse comme
les ours quoi ils vivent tout l'hiver
sur leurs graisse en attendant qu'il
fasse beau tu vois et lui non lui il
avance là-dedans dans ce pays donc il y
a même pas un Inuit qui qui fait ce que
vous avez fait quoi mais c'est parce que
les émissions sont pas cons déjà et puis
en plus les Inuits chassent
au début de l'hiver voilà et puis
l'hiver il reste parce qu'il peut il
voit rien et puis moi si je restais je
rêvais que j'ai été obligé de marcher en
fait de rester vivant et alors Mike
votre la tombe dans laquelle vous
habitez là en quoi il est il est déjà
nylon
traité en fait que ça brûle pas et puis
en même temps les problèmes c'est que tu
as quelque chose à moi 50 que tu peux
pas vraiment plier parce que les nylon à
moins 50 à moi 60 si tu le PLIE deux
trois fois ça casse comme l'hiver tu
viens vraiment cassant et puis on a fait
alors et puis là tu dois faire vachement
gaffe quand tu quand il fait vraiment
trop froid ta mère tente pas de la
mettre de mettre la tente et puis tu
dois marcher en fait je peux rester
vivant vous avez quand même envie de
faire pipi de temps en temps écoute si
tu la sors c'est pas évident parce que
tu le trouves pas déjà c'est ça
il fait si froid que ça tu parles de toi
c'est c'est
5 litres de l'eau de l'eau avant de
dormir je bois 5 litres faites ça me
permet de réveiller chaque 1h chacune
heure et demie comme ça je gèle pas en
dormant et puis je sais que je vais
réveiller pas trop autrement tu quand tu
t'endors à moi 50 au moins 60 il y a si
tu dors trop profondément en fait tu
peux jamais tu vas jamais te réveiller
tu vas gérer ça veut dire que la seule
façon de vraiment c'est d'avoir envie
pisser et puis là je pisse dans une
bouteille et puis parce que la pissé à
30 cm je prends les bouteilles et puis
je chauffe mes pieds parce que mes pieds
à l'extrémité les actes couchage
moi je me suis dit c'est bon ce que tu
dis parce que je me suis dit attends
tout est bidon un moment c'est tellement
énorme ce qu'il a vécu que tu dis c'est
pas croyable ça jamais été faire pendant
l'hiver extraordinaire et alors en fait
tu tu tu savais pas un intérêt à
attendre tu peux en disant l'hiver si tu
vas dehors tu peux baisser ta pantalon
et puis tu peux sortir peut-être 10 % et
puis tu dois
mais tu sais impossible de de d'exposer
ta peau
en moins 50 et - 60 ça veut dire que tu
passes un intérêt à la tente il y avait
une trappe à l'intérieur d'attente que
je pouvais faire un petit trou ouais
quand un chiotte en intérieur latence
tout de suite quoi ah oui c'est solide
comme ça tu nourrir un peu des animaux
alors c'est incroyable le pire de tout
c'est quand il y a l'incendie parce qu'à
un moment votre bouteille de Benzin
tombe sur le sur le et alors là en plein
milieu de cette immensité glacée et
ultra froide il y a un incendie et tout
brûle quoi c'est à dire la tente brûle
tout brûle moi j'ai rempli j'ai mes
bouteilles moi 45 et puis un jour il y a
il y avait la température ça chauffait à
moi 20 et puis à moi 20 il y a jusqu'à
moi 45 il y a 25 degrés des différences
et puis là tu vois un peu du fioul qui
comment il dit
là parce qu'il faisait chaud il fil
prenait la volume et puis avec mon
réchaud à l'intérieur latente quand j'ai
ouvert en fait mon bouteille s'agit qui
est partout ça gicle un peu sur moi ça
j'écris sur mon sac de couchage
extraordinaire alors après bon je vais
pas tout raconter mais c'est vraiment
génial il y a l'Alaska le détroit de
Béring la Sibérie il fait tout le tour
le mec et alors parfois vous vous tombez
parce que votre corps refuse de vous
obéir et là vous la tentation de ne plus
vous relever la tentation de de vous
laisser mourir et si vous entendez la
voix de vos filles
les problèmes c'est que quand on
commence de gérer on sait vraiment pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec nous et puis
là c'était après 12 heures de marche je
voyais un nuage noir qui arrive sur
l'horizon et puis je disais est-ce que
j'essaye d'être de marcher un travers de
ces tempêtes ou est-ce que j'essaye de
mettre la tente maintenant et puis j'ai
fait une erreur je disais mais je veux
marcher un travers parce que je peux
gagner peut-être 5 à 10 km et puis là
c'est sûr que la tempête a pas arrêté
pour trois jours et puis il y avait un
moment que physiquement tu es tu es
tellement fatigué la luge derrière toi
pèse la 150 à 60-160 kg et puis un
moment que tu peux plus tirer et puis là
quand ils vont remontent à 150 km à
l'heure ils vont avenue du Nord moi je
marche vers l'ouest ça roule en fait
quand on traîneau sur la glace et puis
tu es embarques avec et puis là tu dis
mais je peux me lever juste pour encore
ramasser du vent je préfère de mourir
parce que comme ça je n'ai plus besoin
de tirer la vue je n'ai plus besoin de
faire quoi que ce soit je peux créer ici
il est vraiment allé au bout le mec et
puis on a une vie pépère finalement
[Musique]
j'ai fait trop de créneaux dans la vie
dis-moi Jean-Pierre t'as pas été très
surpris en fait par la discipline de la
première compagnie parce que tu as été
élevé dans une pension anglaise en
Argentine où tu as pris des coups
j'ai pas pris des coups il y avait dans
le règlement il y avait ce qu'on appelle
les positions corporelles c'était normal
si on a tous vu if et une palme d'or à
Cannes ça fait partie intégrante sauf
que le règlement est très précis quand
on fait une connerie on sait ce qu'on
risque ce qui est pas toujours le cas
ailleurs
des filles par exemple c'est 20 coups de
canne en tous les cas c'est dommage que
tu aies quitté la première compagnie
parce que tu étais devenu la la mascotte
des téléspectateurs tes ronflements tes
douches tout nu c'est les gens c'était
habitués l'idole des radiologues oui
l'idole des radios
c'est ça nous appartient pas moi je ne
sais pas ce qui montre je ne sais pas ce
qui filme donc et pourquoi tu es devenu
la bête noire des autres
parce qu'ils avaient peur peut-être que
j'aille en finale alors que j'avais pas
fait d'efforts physiques
je détestais t'as vu en revenant tu as
vu les images tu as vu comment ils te
cassaient la chose
j'arrive pas à le en vouloir
d'un cercle fermé ils pensaient tous à
gagner donc
Italia alors que c'est même pas qui tu
étais c'est même pas que tu avais joué
dans un gemme avoir vu dans votre
émission très bonne je ne savais pas
très bien ce qu'elle avait fait dans la
vie non plus
je n'ai jamais parlé de métier pendant 6
semaines jamais j'ai jamais raconté ma
vie d'acteur là-bas
pourquoi tu as fait la première
compagnie
pourquoi j'aurais pas fait c'est un clin
d'oeil à ton fils qui a réussi grâce à
love story
je pense que Benjamin il a pas réussi
que grâce au love story il est devenu
connu grâce à love story mais disons que
ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
ou ce qu'il a fait après prouve qu'il
avait quand même un potentiel suffisant
pour réussir
Benjamin aujourd'hui c'est mon fils
toujours ça n'a pas changé
[Musique]
au cinéma beaucoup comme beaucoup
d'autres
c'est comment de jouer dans un James
Bond le rôle que j'ai eu c'est très
frustrant ouais surtout que lui il m'a
même pas reconnu il m'a pas vu dans le
film j'ai des moustaches si vous êtes
pas James Bond ah non surtout pas
t'aurais aimé être un héros une fois
j'espère que je suis le chien
c'est dur d'être acteur papa ah oui
de tracteur pastard
qui a été faite sur les 10 métiers où on
gagne le moins d'argent en France il y a
moins de 750 euros par mois il y a des
intermittents du sprint
dis papa
tu as pas eu honte de faire la première
compagnie pas du tout c'est alors là
encore moins que le reste j'assume tout
ce que j'ai fait depuis 35 ans tu as
gagné du blé avec ça papa comme tout le
monde
[Musique]
dis-moi tu t'es vraiment blessé ou tu as
fait ça juste pour vendre la pêche
la neuf elle a dit c'est ce que tu crois
que vraiment à courroux l'hôpital de
Kourou on fait des fausses radio
arrêtons exprès
dis papa oui tu crois que j'ai eu raison
d'écrire mon livre l'an dernier non pas
vrai
tu en penses quoi de ma carrière papa de
mon fils très fier et la glace beaucoup
de gens et ça me fait rire tu es fier de
moi oui il est fier de moi
normal
tu sais dans le temps avec le temps qui
passe on sait jamais dit papa tu as eu
honte quand j'ai fait love story
surtout alors là je veux dire alors je
l'affirme haut et fort surtout pas tu
voulais que je fasse quoi quand j'étais
petit papa
je crois que le métier d'un papa c'est
de laisser faire son fils ce qu'il a
envie de faire et il a fait ce qu'il a
eu envie de faire connerie dis papa papa
il y a des trucs que tu m'as jamais dit
papa à lui non à vous peut-être
tu m'aimes
vous ou lui lui oui dis papa tu as peur
de mourir
évidemment c'est un truc de podcasts
dis papa oui tu as des regrets sur ta
carrière c'est déjà énorme d'avoir de
dire depuis 30 ans je vis de mon métier
c'est déjà énorme sans être comme vous
dites une star ou une vedette
tu as pensé quoi de ta vie papa à ma vie
formidable ma vie il le sait formidable
tu peux pas savoir
pas mal comme réponse mais elle avait le
pendant de ses défauts elle avait
beaucoup de qualité oui
papa tu as jamais eu envie de lui casser
la gueule il m'entend à mon temps non
jamais non mais maintenant jamais
[Rires]
malgré ce qu'il a fait à maman tu as pas
eu envie de casser la gueule mais non
s'il l'a fait ça regarde maman et mon
ex-femme il l'a fait j'étais pas là
t'as pas un peu grossir récemment non
j'avais 10 ans que je grossis j'ai
oublié gris selon les rôles selon quand
tu maigris que tu grossis pour tel ou
tel rôle on voit pas tellement la
différence aussi juste pour info c'est
dans quel film où tu étais maigre
Jean-Pierre
j'habite
chat
la dernière fois c'est
Jean-Pierre la dernière fois c'est Hervé
bourge qui est reparti en étant de chat
mais je crois qu'il a touché un ami
depuis je crois
c'est un jeu c'est un jeu et là il faut
que je fasse quoi bah tu touches la [__]
d'un mec ça devient le chat voilà mais
il faut le faire discrètement
mais tu as une minute sinon tu restes
habillé toute ta vie attention
tu me rends pas Jean-Pierre
je crois que je me suis pété une côte oh
non oh non
c'est normal avec maman
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors Guillaume Cochin vous êtes
architecte romancier et vous êtes le
mari de pericocha pas de mince affaire
que nous admirons tous les jours chez
Laurent Ruquier comment ça se passe ça
va c'est plus dur que d'être écrivain
qui s'appelle lui connaît parce qu'il a
fait voilà c'est très marrant
c'est vraiment très marrant allô oui
dehors
je viens si tu veux j'ai pas de problème
[Musique]
évidemment j'allais j'allais faire le
laisser venir au casse-pied tout seul
mais un peu dommage que tu étais là
parce qu'il y avait un truc entre
Mélanie et Guillaume là
vu que je vous ai tous les deux une
interview alerte rose
est-ce que tu as besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer
moi je dirais les deux ça dépend des
jours
et toi moi ça dépend de la fille
quelle mouche c'est quoi ta première
pensée perruque quand tu te trouves en
face d'un mec séduisant
je me demande si
la vérité
la vérité c'est
est-ce que je peux lui plaire est-ce que
ça peut aller plus loin est-ce que je
sais pas non franchement je sais pas que
tu vois même séduisant c'est ça chaque
fois que je te vante en tout cas c'est
ça
c'est quoi le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pour toi parce que les Italiens
c'est la machine elle avait vous saviez
ça
à l'intérieur hein
Guillaume le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pour toi juste au pied du lit
avant de monter avant de monter
d'autres questions
Guillaume est-ce que tu préfères une
femme qui baise bien mais qui est
infidèle ou une femme qui baise mal mais
qui est fidèle une femme qui baise bien
fidèle
est-ce que tu préfères draguer ou te
faire draguer
ça dépend qui gère pas de moi mais
j'aime bien faire draguer
tu préférerais qu'elle te quitte pour
une femme ou pour un homme pour un homme
je trouve ça plus marrant ah ouais moi
aussi je préfère
est-ce que tu préfères être caressé par
quelqu'un qui te répugne ou battu par
quelqu'un qui t'aime oh bah tu par
quelqu'un qui m'aime ah ça doit être
chaud chez les cochons
est-ce que tu préfères que Perry couche
avec un autre en pensant à toi ou couche
avec toi en pensant à un autre qu'elle
couche avec moi en pensant à un autre
moi c'est pas mal ça quelle couche avec
toi même
et toi tu préfères qui couche avec toi
en pensant à une autre qui couche avec
une autre en pensant à toi
qui couche avec moi en pensant à moi
c'est pas possible c'est trop tard trop
tard
est-ce que bon je vais vingt ans que
vous êtes ensemble est-ce que vous avez
encore un fantasme inavouable et non
réalisé il
avoué non
ouais
est-ce que l'amour est compatible avec
le mariage Perry pardon
la preuve la preuve vivante depuis 20
ans je l'adore et j'espère que ce récits
trompé non trompé non
ça dépend ce que tu suces Perry est-ce
que sucer c'est tromper
si tu mens oui
pour moi tromper ses mentir si tu ne
mens pas mais c'est vrai si tu mens pas
tu as pas trompé donc voilà après donc
sucer c'est pas trompé son lit
tu penses que quand on avoue finalement
non pas quand on avoue quand on dit
c'est pas avouer avouer ça veut dire que
tu as menti et que tu te le reproches et
qu'ensuite tu te dis tiens je vais
l'avouer je vais le dire là c'est pas du
tout ça
donc simuler c'est tromper
c'est le service public
mais là on est obligé d'apprendre des
choses un petit peu aux gens est-ce que
vous éteignez vous allumez la lumière
quand vous baisez chez vous non
franchement non il y a pas de règle je
suis pas une règle toi tu non non j'ai
pas de règles
non il y a pas de règle
c'est quoi la zone la plus érogène chez
toi merci
Thierry avec quelle personne ici
présente tu aimerais avoir une aventure
soit honnête imagine qu'on soit dans un
monde idéal où ça pose pas de problème
on a connu ça dans les années 70 mais
bon maintenant c'est fini
alors on va voir si Guillaume et honnête
avec qui tu voudrais avoir une aventure
là à moi-même ma voisine
il te la laisse voilà Miss France est-ce
que tu préfères une femme belle école ou
une femme moche et intelligente
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu préfères une femme qu'on
prend sans la comprendre ou qu'on
comprend sans la prendre on comprend
sans la prendre ouais j'ai pas compris
tu es capable de ça tu vois on comprend
sans la prendre je préfère une femme
qu'on comprend et comprend pas si tu
pouvais posséder que la moitié de péri
tu prendrais le bas ou le haut le bas le
bas
pourquoi le bas parce que il y a
et tu vois si vous voulez prendre que la
moitié de Guillaume tu prendrais le bas
ou l'eau non moi je prends le haut parce
que tout est dans la tête
mais si justement tout est dans la tête
parce que même si on va parler de
fantasmes sexualité etc c'est aussi dans
la tête donc
au bout du compte
dernière question vous baiser avant le
restaurant ou après le restaurant au
restaurant
ça peut être au restaurant oui plus
souvent après pour plus souvent après
qu'avant chaque fois que j'ai le
restaurant on va rester dans tous les
soirs
[Musique]
alors carte autoflagellation vous devez
ah j'adore ah oui vous fouettez en nous
confiant la plus grande faute de votre
carrière est-ce qu'on a le martinet
Méline ah oui ah le fouet
Jean-Pierre
claquer là
en allemand vas-y là
où est ton péché parce que ça va mal
tourner
[Applaudissements]
la même chose pour moi
laisse tomber
votre premier roman anthologie des
apparitions chez Flammarion on fait
beaucoup parler je dirais même que tout
le monde en parle c'est le cas de le
dire voilà alors le pitch je vais le
faire qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
pas une blague
un livre dans 100 ans
alors le pitch était son éditeur toi
j'ai une telle admiration pour Simon que
je je
peux pas m'exprimer sans pleurer sur son
livre donc c'est un très beau livre bien
sûr alors je fais le pitch d'accord
alors c'est l'histoire de Claude et de
sa sœur marina durant la dolce vita des
années 70 le Palace le Studio 54
Saint-Tropez
Ibiza voilà et aujourd'hui quand le
livre commence Claude touche le RMI et
Marina a disparu voilà c'est le pitch et
il passe son temps à se demander où elle
est et il passe son temps à se remémorer
la bonne époque voilà donc c'est
l'histoire de Claude de Marina et puis
elle est riche et puis à la drogue et
puis elle a frime et tout ça fait une
espèce de
sur la grâce et sur cette gloire que
certaines personnes ont à l'âge de 15-16
ans et qu'elle ne retrouve jamais c'est
proustillant sauf que c'était des gens
qui avaient pas vraiment le sens des
réalités donc ils comprenait pas très
bien comment ça pouvait fonctionner et
il y avait il y avait des tas de gens
qui tournaient autour d'eux comme des
espèces de comme les papillons autour de
la lampe et puis bon finalement ils se
sont fait bouffer alors que la lampe en
général elle bouffe les papillons eux
par les papillons quoi voilà alors on
pense évidemment à Ingrid Kaven de
Jean-Jacques Shaun 8 mois toi non mais
si jamais
pourquoi vous avez édité ce bouquin
Frédéric pour l'argent déjà non c'est
éditeur c'est un métier très pénible on
lit beaucoup de choses
pas terribles et et quand j'ai lu le
texte de libératie je me suis dit ce
métier est une chance ce métier est un
honneur voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire oh là là
je sais que c'est tout ce que vous avez
à dire mais toute la critique littéraire
la saluer il y a pas un journaliste qui
n'est pas été inspiré c'est que des
types qui d'habitude écrivent peut-être
pas des articles passionnants se mettent
à écrire mieux en ayant lu son livre le
talent ce qu'ils concerne voilà bon moi
je vous dis je sais pas je trouve que
c'est c'est fantastique que vous l'ayez
invité
il est très tard
non mais c'est important aussi parce que
c'est bon je ouais je pense que
peut-être dans dans quelques décennies
on continuera de lire son livre et nous
tous on sera oublié
j'avais d'autres projets moi aussi
quel conseil vous lui donneriez Frédéric
à Simon Liberati
de continuer à vivre
c'est pas toujours ce qui ressort c'est
assez très charmant j'ai eu beaucoup de
textes magnifiques etc mais j'avais
l'impression que c'était un peu des
éloges funèbres et bon c'est vrai que
mon livre étant assez négatif et donnant
une image assez positive de la
destruction on pouvait penser que bon
voilà pourquoi il est là essayez de
vendre ce bazar qui après tout n'est
qu'un appel à se jeter par la fenêtre
quand même malgré tout quand on le lit
et
bon ben c'est c'est un peu la enfin je
crois je crois que c'était il y avait
une certaine forme de d'esprit
à cette époque et constitué à penser que
bon
il fallait il fallait y aller à fond et
voilà quoi donc c'est le livre un peu
qui rend hommage à un certain nombre de
gens qui sont plus là forcément il y a
un certain qui ont disparu il y a
certains qui sont encore là mais qui
sont plus vraiment
vraiment aussi jolis qu'ils étaient à
l'époque et et voilà c'est une sorte de
enfin c'est pas un hommage funèbre mais
c'est c'est une forme de lyrisme un peu
un peu un peu nostalgique mais pas
enfin voilà je j'ai pas plus je rends
hommage à un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont plus là
maintenant on passe au musée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas m'imiter d'abord pour commencer
le mec qui présente son émission de
télévision pour la première fois ah bon
et bien bonsoir messieurs
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui c'est
je suis très content de où est la caméra
alors je
moi je trouve qu'il le fait mieux que
moi
alors tu l'as appelé Lucien comme ton
vrai prénom
tu veux qu'il soit peintre ou écrivain
j'aimerais qu'il fasse
comme toi
qui peigne ou qu'il écrit ou qui fasse
de la musique ou qu'il fasse les trois
c'est un chien architecture
mais avec tout ce que tu t'envoies tu
avais pas peur qu'il soit un peu Mongolo
Lulu non
il est mignon
ma bouche pipe de son père ou de sa mère
c'est fini oui tu vas encore faire
beaucoup d'enfants comme ça
c'est le dernier et alors imagine que tu
repars à zéro là tu remets les compteurs
à zéro tu as 01 comme Lulu et puis tu
préfères quoi avoir le Goncourt ou être
numéro 1 au top 50
si tu apprenais que Charlotte se
shootait un jour ça te ferait quoi et
ben je me tue tu te tues
je vais prendre
de support
[Musique]
qui me tuerait
jamais Serge Lupien combien pour le
titre de VSD 5 pourquoi parce que j'aime
pas du tout le terme beurre avant comme
ça
mais je suis pas beurre
[Musique]
pourquoi parce que c'est la campagne
anti-drogue il y a un côté qui m'agace
un petit peu dans son aspect terrorisme
je veux dire la drogue c'est l'alcool et
tout ça c'est aussi du plaisir et sans
le dit pas il faudrait quand même les
gens et tous les éléments en main et
pour être à même de juger après alors
c'est vrai que la drogue c'est de la
merde mais c'est de la merde à longues
échéance et je trouve que c'est bien que
les gens sachent exactement
parce que la drogue c'est une c'est la
mort
c'est pas long échéance comme on tabac
moi je suis alors
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux pas je veux pas que
Charlotte se chute je ne veux pas que
Charlotte chouchoute je ne veux pas que
le lustre
sa carrière très fourni on verra ça tout
à l'heure est-ce que ça te laisse le
temps de t'occuper un peu des dames
quand même bah oui ça c'est un truc par
contre quand je m'occupe le plus
possible le plus possible alors j'ai lu
dans une interview des fois sur scène ça
durait tellement longtemps tu étais
tellement bien que tu avais des
éjaculations sur scène c'est vrai ça ou
c'est la journaliste qui avait inventé
ça m'est arrivé ça m'est arrivé mais
j'étais vraiment bien ce jour-là il faut
croire j'espère que ça va t'arriver
aujourd'hui
dans tous les cas c'est bien tu réponds
avec une grande franchise
le plus mastoc
un pervers le plus pervers
[Musique]
l'indice l'adresse de la plante d'Yves
Simon un hôtel de la Ripaud
voilà
ça va feignasse
Simon Simon ça vient d'où ça ça vient de
l'est de la France et du un peu plus au
sud aussi ça veut dire quoi ça
mon père était acrobate joyeux
non je ne dis rien j'ai pas envie de
vous dire
ma fille
[Musique]
tu vas voter pour qui en 86
ans tu continues
un jour
mimi avec tes beaux yeux là tu as dû
avoir pas mal de propositions de [__] non
mais arrête arrêtez avec vos questions
j'ai pas envie de répondre
je vais te montrer moi
tu vas répondre ouais
je vais répondre ouais
et quand tu baisses éteins la lumière
pas toujours pas toujours la table de la
cuisine ou dans la salle de bain
le plaisir ça fait mal ça arrive ça
réduit le plaisir ça réduit le plaisir
ça réduit le plaisir tu préfères
attraper le sida que mettre des capotes
c'est ça non est-ce qu'on est-ce que la
seule solution pour pas travailler le
sida c'est de mettre
dans la merde
[Musique]
c'est totalement immonde ça me rend
tellement triste de vous voir là-dedans
d'accord
tu as toujours ces chroniques ces
boutons tu les as toujours
comment tu le sais
ils appellent Alberto
oui il s'appelle Alberto il travaille
dans la mode
il y a des magasins
et puis il s'est fait [__] par derrière
c'est pas grave
mais dis donc tu es plutôt le sentiment
d'être clitoridienne ou vaginal comme
fille
je pense toutes les deux
essayez de l'autre je sais tout à fait
de l'autre
mon frère
[Applaudissements]
qui a dit Cindy Lauper
onzie
je crois qu'on a besoin d'un petit
replay
c'est qui
Jean-Luc Reichmann Jean-Luc Reichmann
ça fait un point partout voilà on
commence très proprement avec un point
partout et maintenant je dis Ramzi
deuxième morceau
prêt ouais
un arabe
je l'ai dit
comme c'est quelqu'un de ce côté-là
The Clash
[Applaudissements]
alors
ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
graisse jaune puisque c'est quelqu'un de
ce côté-là qui a répondu je m'en vais
simplement en public
qui joue je veux signaler au public
si vous répondez avant les invités le
point va à l'autre équipe mais si les
invités ne trouvent pas et vous répondez
le point va à cette équipe d'accord ok
c'est clair mais là le public a répondu
de ce côté là c'est donc Grace Jones qui
marque un point c'est l'équipe de base
Jamel concentre-toi
en même temps j'avais jamais entendu
cette chanson
c'est pas un rebeu c'est un remix
attention donc maintenant non non je lui
dis que c'est un rebeu c'est Mustapha
dance ouais
voilà il fallait pas
attention bon vous êtes prêts et là
bombardez
on est à deux partout attention c'est
très bagarré comme comme comtesse ce
soir on passe au numéro 4 Ramzy s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît
il y a une erreur il a dit il a dit le
nom du titre quel est le groupe qui
interprète ce morceau
[Musique]
taisez-vous oui personne ici personne le
public
bravo
[Applaudissements]
ça fait deux points pour l'équipe
attention
c'est ça vous voulez faire au début je
voulais pas faire le malin ok ok
parce que là je vois que l'ambiance
commence à chauffer mais moi j'aimais
pas qui sont là qui viennent mais qui
viennent hey les gars
il y a toutes les cité qui va arriver là
tous les artistes de Darty musique
alors s'il vous plaît les amis vous vous
répartissez voilà vous jouez vous jouez
il joue pas à tes potes
maintenant on passe au numéro 5
attention
on souffle pas les mecs attention
j'ai perdu mes clés
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
ils sont bien tes peintres amzi ils sont
très bien
faut pas chercher c'est Gloria et
Stéphane et Miami
[Applaudissements]
attention pas ce numéro 6 n'empêche que
les trois ont glissé quand même mais bon
[Musique]
Jamel
Jamel tu connais les réponses ou quoi
mais arrêtez Marvin gay ça va c'est
toute mon enfance
[Musique]
j'ai fait la réclamation
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
continue continue
je suis perdu bon
Jamel
mais quatre parties vous laisse tomber
tu mets quatre partout
vous êtes antisémites
antisémite tu perds ton sang-froid
ce que je propose c'est que là
maintenant on est à 4x4 et tout tu mets
tu mets la chanson numéro 7 et tout le
monde joue normalement s'il vous plaît
normalement
la chanson numéro 7
numéro 9 très bien bienvenue Étienne
j'ai une bonne recrue vas-y Ramzy
[Musique]
virgule
[Applaudissements]
encore il a dit avant
[Musique]
dommage
je sais pas qui gagne mais moi je me
régale vraiment
c'est un bonheur on continuera Ramzy
continue
[Musique]
je pense pas non comment tu t'appelles
comment
tu t'appelles
des appels
David
je n'ai pas les mêmes chanteurs mais peu
importe en même temps c'est c'est de la
musique c'est de la bonne musique ça
commence pas comme comme
des fèves là-dessus
originale d'accord
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
c'est la suite là ah ouais tu continues
la suite ok bon vas-y on est tranquille
il est génial
alors il y a une autre version de cette
chanson je voudrais que tu fasses
quelques pas dedans sur scène sur cette
musique parce que je t'ai vu danser dans
ton spectacle
attention danse comme les comme les
petits robots pacifiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vais te dire maintenant on va
passer directement au Banco au Banco on
passe au Bangkok on passe au boncoin on
va pas y arriver donc mes vignes tu es
face ton ardoise
mais c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
on passe
une équipe
c'est chacun pour sa gueule
vous voulez faire un plan
je reste pas pour le
bancoins
Jamel
tu m'as piqué mon bouquin en plus
vous connaissez il faut refaire l'amiral
de Gaulle
Thierry on reprend la 12 là laisse
tomber fais-moi les banques oh non je te
jure je te jure on en laisse tomber
fais-moi les banco là vous avez [__]
une blague c'est pas moi c'est Jamel
le replay du dernier
banco vous connaissez le principe c'est
chacun pour sa gueule donc là il y a pas
de discussion il y a pas de discussion
possible donc pour toi c'est la 14 vas-y
attention je veux l'interprète il y a
plus d'équipe il y a plus d'équipe là
c'est chacun pour soi vas-y Ramzy vas-y
vas-y ouais sur ouais certains ouais on
est parti ouais Jamel tu triches pas
ouais c'est vrai ouais ouais
non ma vie tu l'as dit aussi
[Musique]
donc qui a marqué qui a marqué lors de
ma fille ok on continue
ah bon
attention super banco c'est vrai que
c'est pas possible de faire un laisse
tomber
laisse tomber
ah
[Musique]
bon
c'est qu'une autre
alors les galeiros là
[Musique]
il a faux hein
j'ai gagné le super bon
la dernière fois je suis venu j'ai gagné
super banco
bon maintenant le méga Bongo rencontre
laisse tomber encore plus
[Musique]
le méga banco
quoi
un message de l'huissier du jeu qui
vient de démissionner
a démissionné
attention et celui qui trouve j'ai fait
une visite guidée du 18e
[Musique]
bravo
trop fort il fallait le trouver c'est
vraiment très fort qui chantait j'ai de
François Feldman
l'encyclopédie de la fin c'est moi
c'est pas vrai
compris que tout le monde a gagné tout
le monde a perdu c'est un peu comme
l'école des fans de Jacques Martin voilà
merci Ramzy tu as bien [__] tu as bien
[__] le blind test ah non non sérieux
de toute l'histoire du blanc de tête je
suis là là
tu as raison c'est le plus grand blind
test qu'on ait jamais vu complètement
distroiller mais très sympathique malgré
tout le Dirty Dancing mon frère lâche
rien le 18e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu